for pricing information or to request a
tape
or go online to cspan.org
shop
and click on book tv
now join us live for in-depth with
robert carrow
robert kiro spent seven years
researching his first book the power
broker robert moses and the fall of new
york
the pulitzer prize-winning biography was
chosen by the modern library for its 100
greatest books of the century list
the path to power launched robert
carro's award-winning series on the life
of lyndon johnson
his next book the means of ascent ended
with lbj's election to the senate in
1948
and now the long-awaited third volume
master of the senate is scheduled for
release in april 2002
the third volume follows lyndon
johnson's 12 years in the us senate
for the next three hours robert carro
will be taking your phone calls and
emails as our guest on book tv's in
depth
robert carros in our studios here in
washington and this is what the brand
new book looks like his fourth book
robert carroll's the years of lyndon
johnson master of the senate
mr carrera if you were writing the lead
story based on what you know the lead of
the story based on what you know in this
book what would it be well he came to a
senate where the only thing that
mattered was seniority you weren't even
supposed to speak on the floor the first
year or two in his first two years he
became the assistant leader of his party
in four years he was the leader of his
party in six years he was the majority
leader and then he set out to make the
senate pay us the first civil rights
bill since reconstruction and did it
what's your favorite new thing in this
book
my favorite new thing is the passage of
that 1957 civil rights bill because i'm
interested in political power and that
is an example of getting something
through when it just seems impossible to
do it how did he do it
well
it takes me about 300 pages to tell that
at that time you know there were 15
great standing committees of the senate
i think in that year the southerners
were chairmen of eight and their great
ally carl hayden of arizona was chairman
of the of the ninth they had basically
all the power in the senate uh many of
them were determined that a civil rights
bill not pay us and johnson set out to
get it through by using
every means you know when johnson wanted
to do something
he was going to do it and
he used power he used persuasion
he used guile he used parliamentary
maneuvers which he had brought to a new
degree of effectiveness it's it's in a
whole panoply of ways
you have a picture in your book of
richard brevard russell of georgia
who is he who was he and what role did
he play in the whole civil rights you
know russell is a figure who's sort of
getting lost to american history now and
sometimes when i talk at colleges people
hardly know who he is they only know
that there's the russell center office
building but for 25 years he not only
he defeated every attempt to pay us a
civil rights bill in the united states
center he was a figure on the one hand
of a unique
unique patriotism
i had the respect in which he was held
by his colleagues was unique
on the other he was a great leader
but i
as i say in the book he was a leader in
the worst of causes
where did you get your best information
new information on richard russell well
on russell my wife einer went down to
the russell library
and
spent a lot of time going through papers
that i'm not sure anyone had ever looked
at before i went down to winder i am
indebted to
one of his aides william jordan to take
me and you know you fully understand you
begin to fully understand richard
russell only when you go behind his
house is this family graveyard in a
grove of trees and he built this immense
obelisk immense in terms of a little
town to his father and mother and it
says whatever it says to richard brevard
russell senior
defender of the old south believer in
the new you know uh you start to
understand him down there
you say that
lyndon johnson used to go to baseball
games with richard russell did he like
baseball
john connolly once said to linda johnson
i never knew you liked baseball and
johnson said oh you know i always liked
it of course
he went with russell because he wanted
to get close to russell that was his
great aim when he came to the center he
realized right away that richard russell
was the power in the senate he was
simply the most powerful center
senator and johnson took every means
that he could he joined russell's
committee he actually had wanted to be
on other other committees but russell
was on the armed services committee
because he wanted he said this is a man
whose whole life is the senate and his
work if i'm not on his committee i'm
going to see him only in passing so he
he
went on that committee russell liked
baseball so he went to baseball games
russell was a civil war buff so johnson
said i would just love to go with you to
the civil war battlefields he took every
opportunity he could to be close to
russell
this book has something unusual in the
opening
part of the book i don't know i've ever
quite seen this before where it's the
color photograph of the current united
states senate was that your idea yes it
was but you have to say it's something
that's almost never done anymore because
it's so expensive to do colored end
papers and i said but that is the place
i wrote about
and it would be great to have a picture
of it then in the rear end papers we
have the old senate chamber before they
moved into this now is this the chamber
as it is today or as it was during
london johnson's time as it was during
lyndon johnson's time you see how dim it
was because they didn't have television
then so one of the aspects of the
chamber was its cavernous gloom when you
look down
across it
you went to some lengths
to get a sense of what the senate was
like during the time that lyndon johnson
was there including having senator bill
bradley yeah stand at the desk
yes
if i can see in this picture here where
is that the you can look up on the
monitor and see where is the desk right
here right now yes
on the left side of the center i think
you were pointing to the right side
right there yes that was lyndon johnson
actually it went across the aisle from
it
that was the majority leader's desk and
johnson would stand there at the edge of
the well now that step is six inches
high and everyone would say about
johnson of course was six foot three and
three quarters everyone would say how
when he stood there he towered over
everybody so one day uh senator bradley
was kind enough to arrange for me to
spend an entire afternoon on the floor
of the senate and at the you know it was
a wonderful experience for me of course
and at the end he said is there anything
else i can do for you i said actually
there is i've always wanted to know
exactly how high lyndon johnson towered
and you i know since i'm a princetonian
i used to follow his basketball
team around
are six foot four and a half almost
johnson's height would you mind going
over to the desk and standing there well
the senate was still in session
amendments are being voted on bradley
stood there was actually bob dole's desk
at that moment but senator dole wasn't
there every so often senator bradley
would look at me and said am i here long
enough you know but i knew i was never
going to get a chance like this again
and you know it was it's funny if you
make yourself if you are lucky enough to
do that and through senator bradley's
generosity i was able to you see
suddenly you realize he's so tall and
the deus and the senate is so low that
when nixon is presiding as vice
president then johnson is majority
leader and they are dueling over civil
rights one of the things you see is that
their eyes are almost
the same level then you also see how
tall johnson look you know he'd stand at
the edge of the well and he ran that
senate i mean he wanted the vote you
know the senators would be in the the
well but when johnson wanted the vote to
go faster he'd raise his arm and go like
this and the clerks would call the old
faster if he didn't have all his men on
the floor if he needed to round up some
more votes he would use this
motion and the vote would be called
slower
senator historian told me that you even
had the lights turned off in the senate
so that you could see what the yeah it
was like now because there's television
cameras and all that when did you do all
this well i it when you said during this
last 12 years but i realized that the
senate
then looked very different although the
furnitures or furnishings are basically
the same it looked very different
because the lights were so different
i want to say that you know when you say
the senate historians it's the historian
richard baker
and his associate historian donald
ritchie they would go to any length to
try to help me visualize the senate as
it was then once i said i have to see
the lighting as it was somehow they
managed to come up with
an elderly electrician who remembered
the configuration of the lighting as it
was before television and they recreated
it for me how many years have you been
working on leonard johnson
uh well the power broker came out in 74
i think i started in 76. so i've been
working
25 for 26 years the power broker was
about what
they were your first book yeah about
robert moses the man who built all the
highways and parks and
everything else in new york basically
and here's what it looks like it's a
huge book is this was this the biggest
book you've ever written
yes this one is close to it though you
know the master of the senate this that
was about 1286. i forget i was going to
look 1167. thank you
your current book is 1167. your first
book on london johnson was called what
uh the path to power and what was it
about well that was about johnson's
boyhood and his his career is growing up
in johnson city his creation of his pers
first political machine is going to
college is teaching mexican-american
children down in catoola and
which is my favorite thing of all the
johnson books a chapter called the first
campaign so when johnson is 28 years old
no one even knows who he is in his
district and he decides to run for
congress
and it's one of the most
fascinating examples of a man who will
will exert any effort to win uh
and he does and i tried to show through
that campaign what is rural politics as
opposed to big city politics and this
second book came out in what year the
sec came out in 1990
and what's what's the time period for
this well that deals with the seven
years what i call johnson seven years in
the wilderness uh where he's
he's stuck in the house he sees no way
of getting to the center of getting more
power he's just desperate
he starts to use his political influence
to sell his political influence to make
money through his radio station
it's a terribly unhappy time
for him and at the end he decides to
take what he calls the all-or-nothing
gamble
to run against the most popular
politician in the history of texas
governor coke stevenson because he sees
nothing else to do i said without power
he didn't want to stay in washington and
he didn't want to just be a member of
the house because he didn't have any
power there and most of that book is the
really the story of a stolen election
uh in this he didn't steal just
thousands of votes but tens of thousands
of votes
and
at the end he won by 87 votes over koch
students in about 17 or 18 minutes we're
going to open it up to phones for two
and a half hours give you a chance to
talk to robert carrow who is coming out
with right now as we speak with this
brand new book
called lyndon johnson master of the
senate this will be in your bookstores
on april the 23rd
which means it's a few days left if
you're watching this live before you can
see it live i mean before you can buy
the book um you
dedicate most of your books for aina
always and for robert gottlieb 30 years
four books thanks
who's ayna
einer is my wife
and of course she's the whole team i
mean you know when i read about other
historians having teams of research
assistants einer is a medieval historian
she has a masters in medieval literature
and i want to say
she's also published one wonderful book
which is doing very well and is just
finishing another one on france now
but she also works as my researcher
and has for
ever since
the power broker
well we've talked to you many times but
we've never seen aina so this time we
took our cameras to new york chatted
with her a bit and here is a little bit
of what she had to say about how she
does her work and this whole business of
research robert carroll's wife
i was working on my
graduate thesis
in medieval french history and bob heard
his back up at harvard
and
he couldn't get out of bed so he asked
me to go to awesome
i can't remember exactly what it was he
asked me to go to some
records department in long island for
the moses book
and
i would call him i mean i knew how to do
uh primary sources etc but i didn't know
how to do
you know the type of research that a
reporter knows how to do which is go to
the primary sources in a uh
in a municipal building
and
uh find out according to the maps who
owned what and go back and find out who
sold it when or all of that and he we
would i would have to run to the
telephone like every 10 minutes and say
well i found this now what
and he would tell me the next thing to
do
and it was just so much more fun than
translating medieval latin
i mean
i got to interview
people
and
that were alive and you could take the
documents and ask them about it which
you can't do with medieval history
and
um we sort of been working ever since
how long have you two been married
uh
40 43 years children i have one son how
old is he uh 44. what's he do for a
living he's a lawyer
is it harder or easier or do you know
having a research assistant who's also
your wife
well einer is a
it's easier because uh einer is a unique
research assistant i mean i really first
place i could never trust anybody else
you know i always have to see everything
myself even when she finds something i
always sort of have to see the file but
she knows
what i'm looking for and also she has
this you know it's a very um
ingenious and it's a very mind of great
ingenuity uh where she can think of
where to look for other things she's not
einer is a little shy so she doesn't
like to do interviews but if you put her
down in a library she's just happy and i
mean that's she loves to go through
documents where'd you meet her i met her
when i was at princeton she i met her at
a hillel on friday night at princeton
bob carroll is a 1957 graduate of
princeton we're going to show you where
he works in a few minutes
and we're going to go to phones in about
14 minutes and i want to ask the
audience and we've done this before
because of the way he's writing these
four books
to call in about anything but the lyndon
johnson presidency
lyndon johnson was president 19 november
1963
up through 1968 but that book is not
written yet how long how far along are
you on the research well i've done a lot
of the interviews for it because a lot
of the people who i needed like george
reedy for example or horace busby i knew
they were getting old i'm going to die
actually they did die so i had i went
through all their files of memos and
meetings and then i would do a lot of
interviews with them so that portion i'm
i'm fairly well along in that but
there's an awful lot of work to do
and i also you know because i always go
to the i'm gonna go to live in a
southern city for
as long as it takes for me to find out
exactly what differences
it made in the life of black people in
the south that lyndon johnson got them
voting rights do you know where you're
going to live yet no i have to it takes
time to figure that out when do you
think he'll do that oh pretty i'm going
to take i'm going to go on a book tour
now then we're going to go we always
spend two months in france
uh and then i'm going to start and what
about the idea i know you've mentioned
in the past going to vietnam
yes well you remember everything that's
the two things that i want to do because
if i can just say
i try to write about political power and
i feel that you don't write about it
fully enough unless you write not only
about the man who uses it but about its
effect on the people on whom it's used
for good or for ill now for good lyndon
johnson through his great civil rights
acts of his presidency and his voting
rights acts
transformed the political power of black
people in america i want to go to a
southern city and see what did that mean
you have sewers now you didn't have are
your sidewalks paid where they weren't
paid before how do you feel about the
sheriff now now that you can vote for a
sheriff are your schools better did i
say that already exactly what difference
do you have more hope than your father
did that your children's life will be
better than yours because of lyndon
johnson
however
the other side lyndon johnson's
presidency is vietnam
and uh one of the things i intend to do
is to try to show what it means
when a modern industrialized nation
makes war on certainly not a primitive
nation but a rural peasant nation so i i
want to go to vietnam and see how that
works and probably live in a vietnamese
one of these vietnamese villages that
were bombed by b-52s you know the
horrible thing about that brian is the
b-52s flew so high that not only were
they invisible from the ground but you
couldn't hear them so these villagers
never even knew they were being bombed
until the bomb had the bombs actually
do when do you plan to do this
well i haven't worked out first i'm
going to do the southern city
uh then and you know you say what
priority do you have well there are
people in the johnson administration who
are they're all getting old you know
i've interviewed some of them some of
them don't want to talk to me but there
are a lot who do that i'm not done with
yet in order to interview someone
intelligently you have to go through his
fire so you can say in this meeting you
said so and so what were you talking
about
um you have to do that
in the southern cities the people who
remember life before lyndon johnson
before the voting rights act they're
getting old so i have i i feel this and
basically i'm getting old
you feel this terrible sense of urgency
i'm going to do it as fast as i can how
old are you 66. and you've been working
on london johnson for 25 or 26 years yes
how have you been able to make a living
at this
well um
[Music]
with difficulty but i mean at first you
know when we did the power broker it was
just seven years of being broke you know
i mean i just remember the power broker
of seven years of
worrying about how we were going to pay
the rent every month
but then of course
and that didn't really sell very much
when it started now of course it's going
on it's in all these colleges so it sold
a lot
but the first johnson book became a best
seller i think was on the best sellers
for like half a year the second one
became the number one bestseller in the
country how i have no idea i i
i never thought it would
and
it's now easier i wouldn't say it's easy
because no matter how much money you may
make on a book when you divide it by
seven or nine years
it doesn't come out to someone do you do
speaking to make money do you write
articles to make money i never write
i've only written one article when i
left the newspaper business i said
i'm not i'm going to try not to do
anything but write books so in the in
the i left newsday to do the power
broker in 1967.
so in those 34 years i've only done one
one article the new yorker asked me to
do one on the 25th anniversary of the
power broker how i came to write it
now people think that all my i'm doing
magazine articles because like the new
yorker just excerpted master of the
center and the new yorker ex did six
parts on means of ascent and the
atlantic monthly did five parts on uh
the path to power so i'm in the
magazines a lot but they're always
excerpts from the books power brokers
still sell
yes i think
it seems to sell more every year
thousands of copies a year yes it does
and and i know at one point random house
did a computer print out some years ago
of how many colleges you know order each
book at least i think 50 copies of each
book and it was used in that amount at
least in 231 colleges in the united
from your states
and first of all i want to know whether
this is leland oles has this story ever
been told before no it hasn't uh it's an
amazing no it hasn't who was he leland
olge was a
reformer a liberal and idealist who
franklin roosevelt made his new york
state power commissioner that he
reformed the bringing of electricity to
new york state when roosevelt became
president he brought leland olds to
washington to try and regulate the oil
and natural gas industries
he was the chairman of the federal power
commission and in this book
lyndon johnson because he's representing
the oil men and the natural gas tycoons
in texas
sets out to and succeeds utterly
in destroying leyland owns
how
well
i mean basically by
making every not only calling him a
communist the great line in his speech
is do we want a commissioner or a
commissar not the great one
but by persuading the other members of
the senate many of whom knew leland olds
and almost all of whom admired and
revered him for his idealism and his
honesty and his unique grasp of public
power in america persuading them that
back in the
1920s the beginnings of the 1920s he had
been a communist because he worked for
he was a liberal he was a radical he's
never a communist in fact when he tried
to create a new political party in in
michigan he was the first guy to put in
clauses that no communist could be a
member of the party but because johnson
used a lot of levers to do this the key
one was probably that he worked for
syndicate it's called the federated
press which was like the associated
press and among its subscribers that
took old's article was the daily worker
and johnson succeeded in making the
senate believe
overwhelmingly because he had a great
ability to convince people of whatever
he wanted that in the 20s because of
this leland olds had been a communist
and the senate voted not to confirm him
and olds's life
was totally destroyed
can you remember how you first came on
to that story
uh well that's
well
it's interesting i thought i started to
read the hearings you know this has been
treated in other johnson biographies in
really a cur a cursory way you know
i am not the first person to say that he
you know
uh used mccarthy tactics three years
before macarthur you know or two years
before mccarthy but when i started to
read the hearings which are
well i forget perhaps 300 pages of how
johnson did it when he had olds on the
stand
i remember sitting there i said
i've never read anything like this in my
life he is destroying this man he's
motivating the other senators working
them up you know the the
homer k parts these
republican
reactionaries i have this line in there
they took turns firing questions at them
two senators who were conservatives and
one who was supposed to be a liberal
lyndon johnson
i
read those hearings and i said
i'm not going to even think about this
for about a week
i want to see if maybe i'm exaggerating
the horror to me of what i am reading
then i went back and read them again i
said no i'm going to tell the story
i was unable to tell it
in more detail
because you had to go back to olds his
entire life uh and his daughter
uh
whom i really don't i if she's still
alive uh zara zara old chapin
zarathustra he named it uh zarathusta
old state but
helped me understand her father of
course he went back as i do with
everything i went back he went to
amherst i learned about him in college i
learned about his early reforming
efforts which was sort of noble you know
he and i learned about i mean this was a
unique man so i tried to find
all you know people would say to me he
inspired all the young staffers on the
federal power commission you know that
they could do something that they could
regulate the utilities if they would
only learn the for you know
how to do this mathematically
so i found as many of them as i could
four or five of them and they would
explain to me how old's did it and of
course
i talked to johnson's people
who were there at the time who excused
john connelly and harris busby walter
jenkins who of course
attempted
to persuade me
that this wasn't really so bad you know
at least one of them tried to persuade
me that legal knowledge was a communist
in fact two of them tried to persuade me
that legal knowledge really was a
communist
uh but unwillingly as
they gave me a lot of information on how
johnson worked to destroy this we know
it's a story that's never been and i
said you know
people ask why my books take so long i
just said i'm going to tell the story
and
um
it did take a long time and a lot of
pages to tell it here's a picture of
congresswoman helen gagan-douglas
the story about helen gahegan douglas
and her relationship with lyndon johnson
has it been told before
and if it has how much new information
do you have on this oh i tell it because
i mean she was had an affair with lyndon
johnson the significance to it of it to
me
uh
was not was
in that johnson flaunted it he showed it
off you know i write in there how he
made
he took care to arrive at capitol hill
every morning holding her hand both of
them were married at the time yes
um
it's not
you know johnson had a lot of affairs
i don't consider helen gahagan douglas
the affair with her although she was a
very famous woman i don't consider
that's very significant in his life
except for the flaunting of it because
you couldn't write about johnson's early
days in the senate or his last days in
the house without
you want to describe how he arrived on
capitol hill he arrived in capital
holding her hand every morning
um and they'd walk around capitol hill
together she was very i think attracted
to him the significant affair in
johnson's life and there's only one was
an affair that had begun
much earlier with alice glass and which
is described i could not write you know
the power broker i managed to write
1286 pages whatever you said it was
although robert moses was considered one
of the great um
ladies man or lotharios of his time and
had affairs you know with very
prominent women and you could have had
you know a lot of headlines in the book
i managed not to really go into his uh
sex life at all because it had nothing
to do with his work and uh but with
lyndon johnson you don't you don't
really have to talk about most of his
affairs
they don't have a relationship to his
public life alice glass
that relationship did because
she was this very sophisticated
hostess of the greatest state in
virginia when johnson came to washington
as a 28 year old congressman
she taught him how to dress you know she
taught him what side of his face to get
used for photographers but she also and
she was very beautiful and uh
this went on a very long time the reason
that you have to go into alice glass
is that it he also valued her political
advice at times above anyone's when he
was out in australia if i can give you
just one example 1942 you're allowed one
phone call he has to decide whether he's
going to run
run again for the house or run for the
senate in 1942.
he's allowed one phone call he doesn't
make it to the white house he makes it
to alice glass how do we know this
because
and they asked what should which one
should i run for because i found in the
johnson library her telegram back to him
i
the exact words are in the book but it's
something to the effect everyone else
thinks you should run for the senate i
think you should run for the house and
he runs for the house you really can't
tell his story without
telling her
this is the new book brand new from
robert carroll being your bookstore is
april 23rd the years of lynson johnson
the master of the senate
and our phone lines are open the numbers
will be up there on that screen you can
begin dialing now and we're going to go
to calls for the next two and a half
hours robert carroll down this morning
from
new york city where he lives born and
raised and lived
on the on the central park west correct
you still live there yes well we didn't
live that we didn't live in new york in
manhattan for about 20 years when i was
a reporter on news day we lived in long
island and i was doing the power broker
we were broke and lived up in riverdale
in an apartment and then we moved to
texas but when we
in 1981 when we decided we were able to
move back to new york aina said where do
you want to live i said basically i only
want to live on central parkway let's
show some video as we take our first
call of your office which is on west
57th street you've had this office for
how long
uh i guess 15 years because i'm just
about to sign another lease there it is
in the fisk building and you're how far
away only several blocks away from your
home yes
and you operate in this office alone
here we are at the hallway
leading up to your uh room
um how many days a week do you work when
you're writing oh every day seven days
yes
this is it this is your your domain oh
god
well
that's the office yes what's on that
bulletin board there on the left well on
the bulletin board which there's usually
more papers than that that's like the
outline of of
uh either the chapter i'm working on or
at one point the entire book that wall
was like 24 feet long and it was at one
point covered top to bottom all the way
across with the album i know when we did
this video you did you were so absorbed
in this you didn't even know we were
shooting the video that's that's true
i'm looking to see how what i look like
when i write i've never seen it before
do you write with that coat and tie on
like that
uh
no but i i i i wear a coat and tie to
work
and i generally work i guess in a shirt
and a tie and a sweater you know and
what kind of typing would you call that
right there
[Laughter]
i'm embarrassed i guess i would call it
but it's very fast i can do that very
fast
what kind of what kind of typewriter is
that it's a smith coroner elektra 210
i've used them ever since i started
writing my books and
they stopped making them my goodness i
didn't know you were doing this how how
close how many do you have left i know
you had 17 in one well at this moment i
have 17 because you know they stopped
making them so many years ago that
whenever a part breaks you have to
cannibalize another machine you know and
you also have to keep a couple down at
the johnson library and a couple in
washington and all uh
so the number keeps going down then i
advertise or ask friends or something
and i build a number of them let's grab
a phone call for robert carroll we go to
tampa florida first up go ahead please
you're on the air yes uh good morning
gentlemen this is dean chambers calling
my question to you sir we turn this a
little louder right down there
yes there you go go ahead sir yes sir my
question to you is as you were talking
about the hearings and fires looking in
the paperwork regarding lyndon johnson
literally destroying that man far as you
know mccarthy tactics my question to you
sir is when you're doing your research
and looking into the lyndon b johnson
era do you find that there's still a lot
of paperwork maybe under the freedom of
information act that you can't get is
there is there quite a bit of access or
what what stage is i mean do you find
yourself coming up against wall as far
as getting access to actual
documentation regarding lyndon b johnson
um well you have um
they're vast sources of um
it's a good question they're vast
sources of paper in the lyndon johnson
library i think the last time they put
out a press release they said they have
34 million separate
papers there on the senate period uh
it's very well it's very well documented
you have uh inter-office memos you have
the memos from other senators uh you
have secretary's notes saying senator
russell called he says he'll do this if
you'll do
that
so
you have a lot of that information now
down in washington i also did a lot in
the national archives to see the
internal records of the senate
committees here's a photograph from the
book richard brevard russell jr being
sworn in as governor of georgia by the
chief justice of the georgia supreme
court richard brevard russell senior
june 27
1931. next call newport news virginia
for robert carroll go ahead please yes
mr carroll my name is matt hale i'm from
newport news i'm a great fan of yours
it's a pleasure to speak with you i
wonder if you could tell me uh what was
the relationship between uh lbj and
jager hoover um does this come up in
your book or will it come up in your
next book that that will come up in my
next that will come up in my next book
uh so i'm not going to go into it in too
much uh depth and answer to your to your
question right now except to say they
live diagonally across the street from
each other on 30th place uh in
washington here's a photograph from 1948
the johnson's at home
that's linda bird there and lucy baines
there with their mother and father
mrs johnson is still alive do you know
how old she is
she born in 9th december 1912 so i'm bad
at math i think it's 89. and when was
the last time you talked to her oh i
haven't talked to her since long before
the first book was published new york
city go ahead please mr caro thank you
very much um i know how you feel about
living in manhattan i'm over on west end
avenue no other place like it
but my question concerns the power
broker yeah and uh triborough bridge and
tunnel authority yeah uh you know new
york city is one of the few places where
there's an intra burrowed toll like the
rockaways and even manhattan uh bronx
and queens because there was
you know obviously corruption in in
putting triboro together would there be
any way to look at that uh transaction
to see if maybe the city could take it
back like we're trying to take back the
public school system and any other
comments you have on robert moses who
well well you'll have a lot of trouble
trying to take it back because robert
moses was a genius in legislation
and the genius that applies to your
question
is that when he created the bond
covenants you know when you you finance
the tribal bridge by selling bonds to
individuals and banks and accompany each
bond as a bond covenant
and johnson would make sure that that
covenant was embodied in the legislation
establishing the authority because the
constitution says that in effect nobody
no it says no statement there's no state
or no federal government or no city can
abridge the obligations of a contract so
those contracts basically say that the
authority can be kept in existence as
long as the authority wants to be in
existence how long did robert moses have
the power
robert moses held power in new york you
know and it was more power
than um
any mayor or governor had or even mayor
or governor combined he had it for
almost half a century for 44 years
hendersonville north carolina you're on
the air
hendersonville are you there go ahead
please this is my name is alan smith yes
i'm wondering if mr carroll has had the
opportunity to compare
the number of votes that were stolen by
lyndon johnson
in the johnson stevenson election
with those that were stolen by mr
stevenson
uh yes i did i went into that in great
detail
did he did how many did mr steve well mr
stevenson you know uh the johnson
loyalists put out the uh
the uh
the argument that stevenson
also stole votes and in texas politics
at the time i'm sure that some votes
were stolen
by stevenson's people but you know i i
thought that the definitive word on this
was spoken to me by a man who was lyndon
johnson's lawyer for about 25 years and
also the man who ran texas for him his
name was edward a clock and he was a
figure of such
power that he was once named the secret
boss of texas
and
he and i became great friends when he
died the texas monthly wrote a piece on
him says he seems to spend the last five
years of his life explaining
how votes were stolen in texas to robert
carro he once said to me
as far as stevenson himself who was
concerned he didn't steal that many
uh because uh he didn't know how
here's a picture of george reedy
one of the long-term aides of london
johnson and dorothy nichols right george
reedy died just not too long ago yeah
how important was he to you as a source
very important to me you know in in the
senate period brian
um
he was
really would accompany johnson uh around
the senate uh a lot of the time of
course wrote his press releases
i
was a very acute political observer and
um i first started interviewing him many
years ago i'd go out to milwaukee
and we'd have long dinners and the
german-american rathskellers there over
these huge plates of sauerkraut you know
chuck root and
all he was sort of touching because he
had left washington and he once said you
know i once apologized for taking so
much of his time
and he said to me uh
you know
i really love to tell you these stories
no one else out here even knows who
these people are that we're talking
about then he went into a nursing home
and
we would talk on the telephone he had a
private room there
and one day when i called uh there was
no answer
i didn't think anything about it that
night or the next night because
sometimes he was out of the room for a
meal or something but then on the monday
after i think it was i read his obituary
topeka kansas for robert carroll you're
on the air
uh i'm randy williams and it's a great
honor to talk with you mr carroll thanks
i i must say i'm in awe of the work you
did on the path to power i've read it
several times i think it's an
extraordinary work thank you very much i
think you caught the young lyndon
johnson exactly as he showed up in the
senate stealing elections
you you found the boy and it turned him
into the man
well in in many respects you know
uh
he was the same however in some respects
uh he wasn't
and uh in this volume we see that while
as he's rising to power in the senate
in many ways he's sort of the same when
he gets powers you know
one of the things i say lord we all know
lord acton's axiom
all power corrupts
absolute power corrupts uh
absolutely
well i'm not sure that's always correct
but what i believe is always correct is
that power always reveals because when
you get power you can do what you want
and
you do
begin to see what's underneath and of
course what lyndon johnson does in this
book when he gets power in 1957 is to
set out to pay us liberal legislation
and in particular most dramatically
as i said before this first civil rights
bill since reconstruction here is lyndon
johnson with sam irvin senator from
north carolina herman talmadge who just
died was former governor and senator
from the state of georgia allen bible if
i remember right from nevada yes can i
tell you something about the hermann
talmadge interview
i had been trying to get to talk to
senator talmadge for a long time and
finally
his wife said he had been in the
hospital in intensive care
so i went down
to see him
it's the kind of thing that you know
really cares some new light on the
senate because he was a member of the
southern caucus which was this very
powerful
block of 22 southern senators
that russell headed and one of the
things that i really wasn't happy about
because i knew the decisions of the
southern caucus but i wasn't really
happy about the interplay what happened
in meetings of the southern caucus how
lyndon johnson persuaded them to go
along with a form of civil rights in
1957
and
you fly to atlanta you drive down as i
remember on hermann calmadge highway he
lives in in i think henry county in the
center of georgia
so you drive down on hermann tallmadge
highway to the exit marked herman
talmadge boulevard then you file follow
the signs to lake talmadge
and there was this very old
very sick very head congestive heart
failure it's a very painful interview
because he almost had to gather his
breath
to give me each answer the answers are
sort of cryptic you know i mean the uh
cryptic is the wrong word they're brief
but he always managed to make me know
what he wanted uh to say
but you never forgot that you were
talking to
one of the last of the true unapologetic
segregationists and he's there and
behind him is my memory anyway in the
same room is a large uh painted portrait
of his brother of his excuse me his
father who is governor you know the helm
tallages held power in georgia for you
know almost half a century between the
two of them whipping gene talmage i
think that comes from his expression
uh i was never actually a member of the
clan but i used to do a lot of whipping
myself so as this man is herman talmadge
is really expressing the segregationist
viewpoint in the 50s you really said god
this well you had a feeling of the depth
of it in the south mclean virginia go
ahead please yes uh robert weiner mclean
virginia yes mr longer
i often recount with proper attribution
your wonderful story of the meeting
between uh lyndon johnson and herman
brown
in that hotel where they're about to
try to get back into the senate race uh
culminating in the question of lyndon
johnson where's abe
i just wonder if you could recount that
because i'd like to hear in your own
words
and if you can't because it is a little
long i wonder if you could give us a
comment on any other information at that
about that meeting
well the whereas they've commented is a
wonderful uh comment i'm really glad
that you that you remember that abe of
course is abe fortis who later became a
supreme court justice but in the time
we're talking about he's johnson's one
of johnson's many lawyers when johnson
is attempting to steal this election
his opponent coach stevenson has
launched
certain legal maneuvers to stop the
stealing i can't remember them at the
moment but johnson has convened 10 or 12
of the best lawyers in texas in this
hotel room in a i rec as i recall it's
fort worth
and none of them know what to do
the thing one of the things about lyndon
johnson that makes him a leader of men
was that however hysterical or excitable
he would be at other times
when it came down to a moment where you
had to know what to do he knew what to
do and made the decision when as he
looked at this room of lawyers that were
all trying to compromise and every
compromise he would wind up losing he
felt he said where is abe as it happened
fortis was in either dallas of fort
worth he came over and one of the other
lawyers in the room
ellie jones said that's the difference
between good lawyers like us and a great
lawyer ford
sat there he listened to us for about
one hour and then he said all you have
to do is this and he wrote out or he
actually had ellie jones write out this
one page brief which uh in effect saved
the election for lyndon johnson for
robert carroll atlanta you're next
hello atlanta you're on the air go ahead
please hi
hi hello bob this is bill jurgen calling
bill jordan who is the man who drove me
down to see her mentality and also took
me to winder hi bob i see where you're
going to vietnam i want to volunteer to
go with you i'll stay over there with
you for three months
i'll introduce you to vietnam just like
i did to lovejoy and to winder
will you let me go with you uh well i'll
let you i'll be happy to have your
company and you know
if i can just take this opportunity to
say bill i i've sent you one the books
just came out and you'll see that i've
what i've said to you in the
acknowledgements which is that i really
appreciated your help because i felt you
knew
that my view of senator russell would
not always be the same as yours that in
the view for segregation it would be
really uh very different but i felt that
you were so determined to help me get
this man this towering figure in
american history right that you never
stopped helping me and that is the kind
of integrity
that i really appreciate
i i think it's sort of inspirational for
me thanks
i'm anxious that you got russell right i
haven't read it but i'll let you know
when i finish okay
lake travis texas go ahead please you're
on the air good morning uh i've already
pre-ordered uh master of the senate uh
by through amazon.com and i had just
received my copy of uh book notes so my
hat's off to both mr lam mr carro i'm a
stone's throw from mansfield damn yeah
and uh the wonderful description of the
hill country and the history of the hill
country on the panther power is just
one of the most elegant things that i've
read it reminds me of shelby foot as far
as the elegance of your writing thank
you i'd like to ask you a question this
concerns
lbj's relationship uh sitting at the
feet of people like fdr and then sam the
daddy relationship that he has
as part of his way to to gain power
i'm not sure whether rayburn was still
speaker of the house when johnson moved
into the senate but would you touch on
the bridge of their relationship as
johnson became a senator and then also
if it relates to that
speak just briefly on his relationships
to both barry goldwater and everett
dirksen i think that might be fun to
talk about can i take a pass on dirksen
and goldwater for the reason that brian
said i'm going to write about them at
real length in the next volume but on
rayburn i'm really happy to talk because
you can't tell the story of lyndon
johnson's life
uh without telling the story of rayburn
you know rayburn loved johnson he was a
you know he's one of these figures he
was speaker now it's gone out of my mind
either 25 or 27 years about a quarter of
a century and he ruled the house of
representatives as basically no one has
ruled it before and or since
and i mean many of the new deal lawyers
that we
you know uh ascribe only to the
roosevelt administration well they were
formed by the roosevelt administration
but it hadn't been for rayburn's on hand
getting it through the house of
representatives getting this legislation
through these laws would not have become
the law of the land
uh he was a very lonely man he never
opened up to anybody
but johnson
who had an entree to him
because his father had known sam rayburn
in the texas legislature
when he came to washington
as a congressional assistant with his
wife lady bird they started inviting mr
sam as he was called
over to their little apartment for
sunday breakfast
and really it was lady bird more i was a
wonderfully gracious person as we all
know who made mr rayburn i don't want to
go on too long here i could tell this
raven i'm going to try and edit it down
now you see one of my books for so long
she made him feel at home so he started
to come i wrote this man who never
visited other people's homes regularly
started to come regularly for sunday
breakfast and she'd make him his
favorite peach ice cream and the kind of
spicy chili he liked and he and lyndon
would sit around and read the sunday
papers
there is a point in when johnson is very
young and lady bird is back in texas
where johnson gets pneumonia i think the
year is 1934 and of course pneumonia was
very serious then
rayburn comes to the hospital
in washington and sits in a straight
chair beside lyndon johnson's bed all
night now rayburn was a chain smoker
and he was so afraid
that he might
wake lyndon johnson
uh
while he if he got up to brush the
cigarette ashes off his vest that
when johnson woke up in the morning
rayburn's vest was covered with
cigarette ashes
uh when johnson in this book that and
johnson rayburn of course plays this
role crucial role in lifting johnson to
power which i described in the first two
books and in this book he's almost
as important as ever because you say
what's the epigraph of this book i like
to write about political power the
epigraph the little thing at the front
of the book is a saying not by me but by
lyndon johnson he says whatever else
they say about me i understand power i
know where to look for it i know where
to find it and i know how to use it one
of the places he looked for it was to
get power over the senate was not in the
senate but at the other end of the
capitol in the house of representatives
because what's the basic thing which was
this genius and power uh
realizes a senator may get his bill
through the senate bill he has to have
passed but it's not going to be a law
unless it's also passed in the house the
only member of the senate who has this
kind of entree to sam rayburn is lyndon
johnson so senators had to come to
johnson to ask him to go to rayburn and
that was a favor johnson did for them if
he wanted to and he used it uh to exer
exact power from them in re exact favors
from them in return here's a picture in
the path to power of london johnson
kissing his father all right
princeton west virginia you're on the
air uh thank you sir mr carr it's truly
a privilege to be able to hear you this
morning thank you i was only 13 when
your first book came out now
i became fascinated with lyndon johnson
at that time when your second book came
out i was in college and i didn't do
that well that semester because i kept
reading it over and over sorry that's
okay i truly enjoy them i'm looking
forward to the third one i was wondering
if you could talk a little bit about
how
johnson's personal relationships with
senators played a role in his ascendancy
to power and whether or not we've seen
that dynamic at all since lyndon johnson
i believe it's unparalleled but but
certainly you're the expert and i would
like to hear your opinion well before
you start just let me show a picture
here of you talking about relationship
robert kerr
senator from oklahoma and senator
clinton anderson from new mexico that's
actually a very significant picture in
relation to what this gentleman just
asked and thanks for you
for your nice words you see how senator
kerr is holding up a finger there so
he's the center of attention in that
photograph when johnson was in the house
of representatives one of the things he
was known for was pushing himself into
the center of every photograph so he'd
be the center he gets to the senate he
realizes that isn't going to work in the
senate so this is actually on the i
i may be wrong i think it's the first
day of the senate or the day that at any
rate that they select their seat
assignments he's posing there with bob
kerr and clinton anderson two other
freshman senators and he lets kirby the
center of attention and that is a key to
the way johnson rose to power in the
senate new york city go ahead please
yes hello mr carol i enjoy your work
very much thank you
i'm wondering i've been reading the uh
second excerpt in the new yorker uh
titled the compassion of lyndon johnson
yes and it goes into great detail about
johnson's interest in civil rights but
also his use of
uh frankly racist language and racist
views yes
and
it seems that he's
done a very good job i think of of
of highlighting one against the other
and how they can possibly come together
and i wonder if you could go into a
little bit more about that i mean he
uses some tough tough language which i
understand is pretty routine at that
time but um but how do you reconcile the
two how did he reconcile the two sides
of it well
that's a that's a really a good question
uh and i i'll try to give you a a rather
short answer to it and say
that it's such a complicated question
that it really
takes a couple of hundred pages in the
book to deal with it let's talk about it
in terms of compassion and ambition i'll
try and just
abbreviate this
lyndon johnson had a true compassion he
always wanted to help poor people he
always wanted to help poor people of
color especially and how do we know it's
true
i'll tell you how i know it's true it's
been said in a lot of biographies and
it's absolutely true that when he was 21
and he needed to make money to stay in
college he taught for a year at the
mexican school i was in quotes in a
little town called catoula texas and i
wrote no teacher had ever cared no anglo
teacher had ever cared if these kids
learned or not this teacher cared and a
lot of biographies have documented how
hard he worked to make them care but
there's something else
that i felt
was the proof
of the truth or the the genuineness of
this feeling because when he was done he
would take the janitor of the school
before and after school each day and sit
with him his name was thomas tomas i
guess coronado
on the steps of the school he bought him
a book and taught him english coronado
says something like the exact quote is
in master the senate says like i would
spell a word and pronounce johnson would
repeat i would pronounce again johnson
would repeat that was a man who really
wanted to help
on the other side uh he was a very cruel
man there was you know with johnson you
are talking about opposites it's why
it's really hard to do it except to lay
it out
in a book
i i have a line in there which says that
these opposites were no less strong
because they were opposite there's the
compassion and there's the cruelty he
liked to hurt and of course if you're
dealing with a black man for example
probably the easiest way to hurt him
is to use some phrase like [ __ ] which
refers to the color of his skin or boy
and i do have in this book
very graphic and dramatic examples of
how he liked to hurt
now what's the story of hurting robert
parker well that's quite a story
this is not i have to say i didn't
research this it's in mr parker's own
book he later became the maitre d of the
senate uh but he um
worked for johnson as a patronage
employee in the in the 40s and 50s and
sometimes filled in as his chauffeur
and uh
johnson once
uh i'm not going to get this exactly
right
johnson would once leaned over and
parker would talk about how in when
johnson died he was filled with this
mixed feelings because he said johnson
got freedom from me and for my people
that we would never had before besides
him he said on the other hand i could
never
forget the way he would hurt me that's
not his exact words my paraphrase and he
recounts this one example in particular
well he said johnson would always call
me if i was five minutes late he called
me a lazy no good [ __ ] that kind of
thing but he said once in his car
well john well johnson's in the backseat
and parker's in the front mr parker
relates in his book johnson leans over
the front seat and shouts and says to
him tell me something chief
does it bother you that no one ever
calls you by your name they always call
you boy or chief
and mr parker says well yes sir it does
bother me because my name is robert
parker and johnson leans over the front
seat and smacks his newspaper down is
and he says something to the effect
listen boy
nobody's ever going to call you by your
name as long as you live because you're
black
says you just got to learn
to sit there like a piece of furniture
and let it slide off you
now johnson was using that i think i
feel mr parker doesn't feel i i but i
think i feel
to give mr parker a lesson that lyndon
johnson felt everybody had to learn
lyndon johnson was a great pragmatist
and a great realist
but he was really saying because he saw
that mr parker was ambitious as he was
ambitious he rose in the senate to
become maitre d at the dining room he's
saying you've got to ignore this just
accept it as part of life that's the
only way you're going to get ahead but
johnson's uh
some of the things that
johnson did uh
really are crew
this is
robert carroll's new book called master
of the senate he'll be with us for
another two hours this book will be in
your bookstores april the 23rd
how many copies first printing
uh two hundred thousand
how many copies did you have uh means to
ascend the first printing
i don't really i don't remember but it
was a lot also uh i mean are you
comfortable this is enough to get
started with
i'm i'm less comfortable that they're
going to sell
that's a lot of books inside is this
photograph by the way of the southern
caucus
sitting around the table are these are
the senators that made up the
22 senators of the 11 southern states
you can see some familiar faces this is
richard russell here
herman talmadge john stennis
alan ellender over on this side from
louisiana sam irvin
john sparkman from kentucky and this is
strom thurman when he was a democrat yes
uh from south carolina and this is james
eastland this man right here with his
back to us is the father of pat
robertson his name was willis a
robertson of virginia next call
alexandria you're on the air go ahead
please hello uh mr cara i've been
waiting uh seven or eight years for this
i read uh listened to both of your uh
previous books on tape yes sir and i
hope you don't cut me off and i
apologize i'm on a speakerphone but my
hands are crippled
first of all how does one reach you uh
to perhaps provide info source material
for the uh
next book
best place to reach me is to look me up
in the new york phone book it's 91
central park west okay good i'll do that
next thing is
a few
i'm going to run off a few things first
of all
laundry day in texas was a wonderful
wonderful
thank you very much
and thank you um i i only can think of
one other are you familiar with larry
mcmurtry
oh sure it's wonderful wonderful yes we
i have met him he's a wonderful writer
you've inspired me to read all of his
books
[Laughter]
the way he describes the history of
texas yes he's wonderful at that second
of all and i have about four three four
brief ones
uh what's your relationship with uh
chuck and linda rob
i don't have a relationship with chuck
and linda rob sorry to hear that um
but i understand why um
what's the third third question is the
power broker on tape
yes it is on a lot of tapes it's
underbridged and it's on a lot of tapes
but it is on tech yes next uh and only
three more questions two more questions
uh the next question is uh um uh
when will the uh new book be on tape
[Applause]
simultaneously
sort of
simultaneously we've had it here we've
i've already listened to it oh yeah i
didn't know that okay and i'll have my
local library the best library in the
world fairfax county public library get
it okay um
and uh uh you i'd like you to talk about
uh
johnson's uh lesson
in stealing elections from his first uh
loss to uh pastor biscuits papi and the
last question is
what is brown and root now what company
is it now what did it evolve into and
thank you very much brian and you thanks
for your culture uh brown and root
if i'm correct was was uh
bought by halliburton that was some
years ago and uh as far i don't realize
the company that dick cheney ran uh
halliburton yes
uh
i don't really know uh
the recent um
things about brown and root
your other question was that terrific it
was that uh i was asked before about
johnson stealing the 48 election in 41
he had one stolen from him because he
made this mistake he was running against
this uh hillbilly singing
uh
former flower salesman from texas passed
the biscuits papio daniel and um
on election day they were both stealing
votes as fast as they could but johnson
made this mistake he forgot this basic
rule of texas politics you never report
your final totals until the other person
has reported his final totals because
otherwise he knows how many votes you
have to steal
to win
johnson is so confident and he thinks
he's won that
early in the afternoon of this day
he allows his final votes
to be reported actually i was never sure
if he allowed it or if john connolly as
chief aide made the mistake of doing it
i know when john connolly
started to tell me about it he said i
remember i cried that day if you knew
john conley
it was really hard to imagine him crying
john conley didn't talk to you for the
first book and he talked to you at what
point then well after the he refused to
talk to me for the first book refused to
answer my letters of phone calls
sometime after the
second book came out
uh
he telephoned me
i'm trying to to remember this
well i remember what he said i don't
remember if he said he'd read the whole
first book he'd read it or something and
he said uh
you got him right on the head he says i
don't want you to do the second volume
without talking you wouldn't talk to me
for the first time i
resisted i saying i tried so hard you
know you never called me back i didn't
say that and so i went down to his ranch
in floresville for three days of really
remarkable interviews i mean they went
from morning to night it was just the
two of us
and um
he would wake me up early in the morning
and in my memory about 5 30 or 6. it was
too early in the morning and we'd go in
and sit on a fence where they were
training his quarter horses then he was
then in the full flush of his financial
success
and there was nothing he refused
to answer for me i don't think there was
a question
that he wouldn't answer for me he was a
guy of unique
political brilliance i mean that second
senate campaign uh which he so largely
ran for johnson against coke stevenson
when he was explaining to me i mean just
to take one one moment here say he says
you know god understand bob this was the
old politics against the new this was
the birth of media politics now the old
coke stevenson was the most popular
governor in the history of texas the
last time he had run he carried every
one of the 254 counties in texas the
only candidate in history who had ever
done that
johnson destroyed him he was a legend in
texas he was called the cowboy governor
he was very poor boy had built up this
great ranch
very conservative man john but very
honest
and beloved in texas johnson destroyed
him he persuaded texas of things about
coke stevenson that were totally untrue
kindly would say you don't understand
bob it's repetition it's repetition if
you got enough and i'm now paraphrasing
the exact quote as in connolly's exact
quote is in the book you have enough
money you can take enough ads you can
repeat things enough so people will
believe anything then i would say well
johnson said coke stevenson supported
taft-hartley or whatever coach stevenson
made a speech and said i've never
supported taft hartley or whatever i
said why didn't that work since he was
so beloved and kindly said you don't
understand
i told you bob
repetition
repetition is what did it and we
understand it and lyndon johnson
understood you know johnson was a genius
i mean he was doing multiple polling i
mean you know
it's not true that no one had done polls
in texas before people had done polls
before johnson said i want polls by i
forget four or five different
organizations i want the questions of
different shades of opinion i don't want
to just know who they're for i want to
know what's motivating them so you know
i so
you have on the one hand and this is
what i tried to show in that book
the old politics coke stevenson
campaigning as he had campaigned so many
times before you know he was the only
man in the history of the state who had
ever held he was speaker of this
the texas house of representatives he
was lieutenant governor he was governor
he had never lost an election certainly
you know and he always won by so much
um
and he always campaigned the same way
and he thought he was going to campaign
the same way against lyndon johnson
which was simply driving from town to
town you get to the courthouse square
someone would have been there with a
bullhorn saying coke stevenson is here
to speak you'd speak to this little
audience you'd walk through the
courthouse in the stores you'd shake
hands you get back into the car and
drive to the next place lyndon johnson
is using the new media politics it's not
television then it's radio and among the
things that i just so i don't go on
forever among the tactics that johnson
used and could use because he had all
the money he needed through herman brown
was he would buy
farmers come in to eat lunch about 11 30
or noon right so they're always at the
kitchen table at noon with their wife
and the radio is always on
and johnson would buy the noon to one
hour on every radio station that came
into a certain area of texas so you
couldn't turn on the radio station
without hearing them
san diego go ahead please
hi
i'm so happy to talk to mr carol i've
enjoyed you so much
uh you're brilliant right
i i have a question about uh comparing
two very famous democratic people is mr
smith of new york which i know you have
a lot of knowledge of
and mr johnson of texas
one seems like a snake old salesman by
your description and the other is
to me one of the noblest men that ever
walked the planet can you really
tell me what you feel about the
difference between these two gentlemen
and i will take my answer off the air
and thank you for c-span i really
appreciate the program thank you which
smith is she talking about al smith the
governor of new york in the 1920s the
first catholic governor of new york ran
for president in 1928 we have a picture
here from the moses book and uh al smith
i believe is that him right there yes
herb layman yeah al smith and august
texture august hector and his son augie
actually wrote the book on woodrow
wilson okay
you have everyone on the show that's a
good book so of course it would be on
you on your show ah you know can i
answer this uh
question in in a way this isn't quite
what you asked but it'll answer it
one of the reasons i wanted to write
about lyndon johnson you know things
change was i thought he was like al
smith
when i was doing the power broker and no
one has written at that time there was
no good biography of smith now there's
one biography but it doesn't really
well it doesn't really capture what a
great speaker uh he was
uh
what did and all the time i was doing
the power broker i realized i wished i
had enough time to do a biography of al
smith because he was a populist he came
from immense poverty very poorly
educated he didn't go to school past the
sixth grade
he was a ruthless politician a tammany
politician but as soon as he got the
power it became evident that what he
wanted to do is help his people he used
to say it's us it's we against them it's
us the votes are down here with us
they're not up on the east side they're
down here in the fourth ward
my image of lyndon johnson before i
started looking into these books
was sort of the same smith was a
populist johnson was a populist both
incredibly poor
both very
badly educated johnson went to college
but it's a college that really we would
consider a high school today
both ruthless politicians in their early
career
but both did things for poor people in
their later career so i thought there
was a real relationship a real
similarity between the two of them uh
which of course
if you've read my books you know i don't
feel anymore here's a picture of uh
lyndon johnson lady bird johnson former
president kennedy lucy baines johnson
and linda bird
johnson robb
you said earlier you have no
relationship with linda bird that's okay
and chuck robb
have you ever spoken at the lbj library
yet
no i've i i was
i would like to say i was never invited
but i have to alter that now the
director of the library harry middleton
for the 19 years that i had been working
there never invited me
about a month before he left
he suddenly uh
said he'd sure like to have me come down
and speak there i said i i said i i i
thought i'd wait uh he's now retired i
said i thought i'd sort of wait for the
next administration but if they invite
you would you go to the library yeah
well i probably would i want to see how
the new administration of the library
differs from the old one have they sold
your books at the library by now
well
for many years they wouldn't sell my
books at the library then the
philadelphia inquirer is as i recall a
reporter i think named jay romano went
down and said he says the only
biographies that are not there then they
hastily put them in you know then after
a few years they stopped again and
someone else came down right so it's an
off and on
one last question i'll take another call
you say and i don't have it in front of
me lyndon johnson was the greatest
senator in history greatest majority
leader greatest majority leader in
history and there's been a majority
leader since what year
uh well that's that that is the question
brian which i have to say is impossible
to answer because they started using
newspapers starting using the word
leader with different meanings you know
a great leader the formal institution of
majority leader it's different from each
party leader and if your party's in the
majority it's majority leader
they did it's different from each for
each party but it's about in the
1930s for the democrats we consider the
first one as a man named kern who was in
during woodrow wilson's time
we're going to talk a little bit about
hubert humphrey in a moment and even run
some audio tape from a conversation that
he had with lyndon johnson but before
that we go to davis california you're on
the air hi this is joel deckler in davis
california however for the first 40
years of my life i grew up in new york
city and just two brief comments
i was friendly with a guy you went to
high school with mike gross i believe
you were the editor of your forest man
high school newspaper yes i yes i
certainly remember my terrific
basketball player right right
the other thing is i i read the power
broker years ago back
18 years ago and towards the end when
groups started standing up against moses
there was a of one jewish group that
protested and the times had this great
headline it said jews protest moses
which was kind of ironic um but my
question is um
recently there's been a spate of
plagiarism amongst
some popular
popular historians i i won't mention any
names but one is actually a biographer
of lyndon johnson
our local newspaper the sacramento bee
carried
an op-ed piece by some historian who
complained about these people not
being forthcoming and saying you're
right i got caught i was wrong and they
and the the author said somebody like
robert carroll would never do something
like that i was wondering what your
comment is upon the about the the spate
of plagiarism by some popular historians
and what it says about the pub either
the publishing industry of morality
amongst certain types of authors
well i'm going to answer it in this way
if there's anything i've learned from my
own books it's not to
think you know anything until you've
looked into it for yourself
and i haven't looked into these
allegations of plagiarism
so i don't know um and i'm not i really
don't know if they're isolated in
advertent instances
or if there's something more serious
than that and since i haven't i'm not
going to
comment on any specific historian
including the ones who have been named
in the newspapers recently
i will say that of course you know
without reference to that
in my view plagiarism is
an unacceptable thing because if you're
a writer what you live by are your words
and your words had better be your own
and if you have to use someone else's
words they better be in quotes
i mean
i'll just take this this opportunity
because he never gets thanked enough for
his work on lyndon johnson
to mention the name
because i quote him because there's a
little phrase he uses
in about lyndon johnson which was so
wonderful i said i can't make it any
better than this so i better just quote
him so his name is ronnie duggar he was
the editor of the texas observer a great
liberal journalist and he speaks in
relation to johnson's uh
helping of of uh black americans he
speaks of his quote
real but expendable compassion close
quote and of course
when you put that in your book put it in
quotes
audience might be interested if you're
watching this live next saturday morning
at nine o'clock on c-span two
robert carroll doris kearns goodwin and
nell irvin painter another princetonian
will
be appearing before a group of
historians in this town 300 of them
over here at one of the hotels we will
carry this live and you will hear a
discussion about all three writers how
they write where they're right when they
write and uh mr carroll will be there uh
at that time uh and that's the way it's
scheduled as of right now doris kearns
goodwin nellervin painter and robert
carroll we go to pleasantville new york
here on the air oh good afternoon what
an honor to speak to mr carroll gray is
one of the greatest writers of modern
times and certainly mr lam one of the
best interviewers on television
well the second half of that is true i
did a couple of things first of all i
took the paperback version of your book
up to my bathroom scale it weighs almost
five pounds
almost five pounds i probably never
would have read it in that form uh you
should promote the fact that all of your
books are available on tape what a
wonderful way to listen i read all of
them
and the power broker was the first i had
the privilege of
listening to that book
two summers ago as i was commuting to
long island on a regular basis driving
over those bridges and they just really
came alive in jones beach uh my country
club uh growing up as a kid uh i can't
wait to go back there and and and see it
again thanks the previous caller one of
the previous callers talked about al
smith yes could you tell us a little bit
about al smith's story how he uh
became an assemblyman how hard he worked
a little bit about bell moskowitz
and maybe about how fdr used him and
took all of his programs and ideas and
put him into the new deal well i'll
start with the end of your question uh
francis perkins roosevelt's secretary of
labor once said you know 95
of everything in the new deal we took
from al smith in new york he's one of
the great social forum reformers in
american history and the fact that he's
almost forgotten to history is one of
the saddest things
that i've ever heard he was the great
speaker you know he had an answer uh for
everything uh
they used to they they used to attack
him or mentioned that he had no
education he said i have a degree ffm
for the fulton fish market because
that's how he worked when he was a boy
to keep his family together he would
work there from something like four in
the morning till uh
into the evening every day rolling these
heavy barrels of fish
up and down uh
someone once chided him uh
on his uh lack of grammar he said i know
grandma when a blue perfect adjective
precedes a noun insert a plus
uh but he really cared you know he was a
he rose to power running errands doing
jobs for tammany hall
then they make him an assemblyman
and they have the triangle shirt waste
fire in new york
when all these
sweatshop
the women who worked in sweatshops
leap from the the
leap from the whatever floor it was and
die
one after the other because the um
uh the exits are blocked because there's
no rules al smith you know is appointed
as an assemblyman to represent tammany
really on this reform commission to look
into working conditions for children and
for women
and one of the men who worked with al
smith on this commission said you know
we'd go to these factories the owners
would say we had no children working for
us what they did they put them into
these seven or eight-year-old kids who
worked seven days a week
from doing from dark to dark
they put them into elevators and put the
elevators between floors so when the
commission arrived there wouldn't be any
kids there this man said i watched al
smith's
face change
when we made that tour of the state and
at the end of it he says you know i
can't write too good
he said
you write the laws
i'll pass them and he comes back to
albany a different man and from that day
on and when he becomes governor of new
york you know uh for for 10 years he
passes he transforms social legislation
in america he's also if i could just say
he was he was a great speaker we don't
have speakers like this anymore uh
robert moses one of his first jobs was
to write speeches for al smith and moses
was a phd from oxford then and he wrote
that the al smith is running against
this republican governor named nathan
miller who's claiming that he saved the
state whatever 14 million dollars in
economies and moses has analyzed this
you know dollar by dollar and disproved
it and he hands the speech to smith
justice smith is going to walk out on
the platform before this huge audience
of farmers in utica
smith looks at the species says i think
i'll say it a little different way bob
he walks out on the platform and he says
i governor miller says he saved the
state 14 million dollars i have just two
questions
where is it
and who's got it
kendallville indiana you're next with
robert carroll go ahead please thank you
for taking my call mr carroll it's an
honor to speak with you thanks and uh my
question i have is about johnson's
character and our nation's character has
to do with loyalty yes and the thing
that fascinates about your books is i
could read these people who johnson
abused and you know how he was to work
with yes and i could just still feel the
affection these people have for the man
uh that some of them have absolutely
at the end did did
horse buzzy have affection for him oh
yes george reedy
um
no
walter jenkins
uh
well jen can i say jenkins is such a
complicated story brian that i'm going
to tell it at length in the last volume
too hard to say that
uh
horace but uh horace buzzy did he
idolized johnson was a great asset to
johnson you know other johnson's aides
have gotten more publicity but in
johnson's early years horace busby was
his
real a real con a real great
speechwriter for him and what about jim
roh he's quoted a lot in your book jim
roh you know uh
really liked johnson you know he's still
alive no he died
he was alive when the first book came
out he spent so much time educating me
on washington he and he and his partner
tommy corcoran you know i used to go
sometimes to their law firm you know it
was uh i think corcoran rowan foley or
something
you know and roe would be giving me this
tour and detailed things and mr corcoran
would walk in
in a very clipped
blunt irish way make the same point they
were great help to me i think jim roh to
very great extent
saw all the sides of johnson
and saw that he could be a great
president that he was a great president
in in
in some ways
um you know in this book it's really
fascinating because johnson relies on he
believes in jim rose i think we have a
quote from george reedy in there he
believed that
roe had the ability to make him pope or
something actually deal with something
as president the reason he believed that
is that roe when harry truman was
running this come from behind his
seemingly hopeless campaign in 1948 roe
drafted a memo
which really laid out a strategy
that if truman followed it he'd win
truman followed it and whether it was
because he followed the memo or not he
won so johnson had this mystical belief
in roe and it's really fascinating that
um
at the moment in 1957 when johnson is
teetering on whether to stop fighting
for this civil rights bill because it
seems hopeless
uh and it does seem hopeless
he's down on the personalities on his
ranch and he gets this memo from roe and
the line that leaps out of it in my
memory is this is armageddon for lyndon
johnson you either pass this civil
rights bill you can forget about the
presidency in 1960. we have an hour and
a half to go with robert carroll we go
to oxford maryland you're on the air yes
thank you for taking my call uh
this is jim dewer
in oxford maryland and i am publishing a
book next year on the nuclear rocket
program
in which senator clinton p anderson is a
key figure
uh i have three questions for you uh can
you comment on the friendship that
johnson anderson had over the years
two
can you
comment on the role of anderson and
johnson in the forming of nasa
and three
i've been trying to find the photo
credit for that photo you showed of
johnson curran anderson and i'm
wondering if you can help me
[Laughter]
i'm afraid i can't help you with a photo
credits you'll have to ask my publisher
and a lot of what you asked me about
anderson uh will fall into the purview
of the next volume so i i haven't i'm
still working on that but in the senate
you know their relationship is very
interesting because they're two very
practical politicians
um
there's a scene which i don't say i
wrote it wonderfully but it's a
wonderful scene when johnson is trying
to pass the civil rights act
um
there's this sticking point
no one seems
no one see seems to find let's see if i
can explain this
if i can even remember it and no one
seems to know a way to get this
amendment drafted uh to alter this
amendment everyone's trying to modify it
clinton anderson is sitting and but the
people are trying to modify it are
southerners and conservatives and the
liberals will never accept it from a
southerner conservative clinton anderson
is sitting there in a corner his desk
was in the lower
corner of the center ark
and he simply crosses out
this um
this clause i managed to f i got this uh
dick baker the senate historian actually
found me uh
the the the the
the draft of the bill with anderson's x
across it
and uh but that wouldn't have helped
because uh
only johnson saw
the use to make of it that this was this
was something being proposed not by a
southerner or a conservative but by a
liberal he walks over to anderson and
says
anderson hands him the thing johnson
looks at it and in one flash of a moment
as the debate is going on around him he
says yes he says but you and anderson
get says get a liberal to to introduce
it and johnson says no you do it
because he knows that anderson is so
respected and as a moderate that he can
bring other votes along with him i
didn't explain that very well here's the
picture and the cut line says new
senator london b johnson allows new
senator robert kerr to take center stage
senator clinton anderson is at his right
he was a democrat from new mexico
did you pick the photos for the book
i know the photos for the book were
picked by the same woman who has
the managing editor of cannot catherine
horrigan who has worked with me for
30 years
she select and
she works with my editor bob gottlieb
who's worked with you for 30 years for
30 years and the two of them in some way
which i'm not privy to uh
she
finds many
the photos
he and she select them they're laid out
by someone else and i have to say since
i have nothing to do with them
that they're really wonderful photo
sections and i think they add something
to the book and kathy i thank you for
them and bob i thank you
for so much as i said in the dedication
now
you did two excerpts in the new yorker
this time one was on the 1957 civil
rights bill yes and the other was on
this man hubert humphrey yes was that
your idea to have those two subjects did
you make the decision in the new yorker
no the new yorker picked what to do why
david remnick the editor why so much
attention on hubert humphrey oh
really good good question
um started out very differently you know
i i it started out as something
for a reason very different i i've never
i've always felt that it's sort of
boring to give the reader a lecture
on a political movement
like um
i said once in the first volume i can
either give a lecture to the reader and
explain what texas populism is i have to
explain what texas populism is because
lyndon johnson was a product of this
but i can either do it
with a lecture or i can tell the life of
sam rayburn whose life embodied this in
this book uh southern racism uh you can
either give a lecture on how it played
out politically in the senate or you can
do the life
of richard russell humphrey i started
out because i wanted to show what
prairie populism was so i spent a great
deal of time researching his early life
and i found out i really only knew
the hubert humphrey
who was lyndon johnson's vice president
who really was a cowed and subservient
uh
character
when i'm doing this i learned what a
great
mayor he was of minneapolis what a
crusader he was as a mayor of
minneapolis there was a very touching
letter in the new yorker in in a
response to my
excerpt from a black woman who said
uh
to the new york thanks for running this
excerpt my mother used to tell me
how because of eubart humphrey i may be
misquoting this letter a little bit but
not much minneapolis was the only city
in the country where a black person and
a white person get could get married and
not have to be afraid walking the
streets you know he stopped when he
became mayor minneapolis was known as
the anti-semitism capital of america he
stopped all that he created the first
fepc in america he was a great crusader
and i decided i want if i told the story
right i could show prairie populism then
came the part that everyone talks about
in the new yorker that's in the book
this incredible speech that he gives on
the 1948 convention that everyone is
saying is the most exciting speech that
i ever heard well you know that sounds
to me like
maybe maybe not
but i finally got a newsreel outtake of
the whole speech it's only eight minutes
long
and it is the most exciting speech
i've ever heard and um
so i try to dramatize his role in civil
rights i'm going to play a audio tape in
a moment but we got callers waiting i
want to grab them mount pleasant texas
you're on the air
yes good afternoon mr carroll good
afternoon you told us of your three-day
visit with john connelly in mooresville
texas can you describe for us your
technique of collecting ideas and quotes
from conley and from others do
do you take notes to use a voice
recorder and how does this affect the
quality of the information that you
obtain i'd like to hang up and listen
please okay
i don't use a tape recorder
uh except in very rare instances because
well i have to tell you that this is
really a minority view
many uh
of the best writers and reporters i
suppose almost all of them
do use tape
recorders and what they say is that
people forget after a while that the
tape recorder is on
i don't believe that
i'm saying that for one minute when i'm
being interviewed do i forget the name
recorder is on
uh
and i feel that therefore the tape
recorder
is in a way
maybe a small way but never an
impediment to frankness an impediment
to truth in a way
when i was still a reporter on newsday i
developed a method of speed writing
where i can get down every word
if
if it's something where every word
should be
taken
i was very interested in regard to that
that i once interviewed
mrs johnson lady bird johnson for some
hours and she taped the interview and i
wanted to check my notes against it
which was page after page of handwritten
notes and when i checked them
against the actual tape there were very
few words that that uh were different
um
i also would like to say since i've said
that and you might say well what if
people claim they misquoted i have to
say there have been a lot of
attacks on my book mostly by well
they've been you know they've been
attacks on my books but nobody
uh has ever
in my whole life
as far as i know and remember claim that
i misquoted what are you going to do
with the notebooks
well i have a real problem is what to do
with the notebooks which contain
information that no one else has because
as i say the lyndon johnson library
which would be the obvious place for
without going into it any further
because i still have to work down there
is not a place that has not been a place
where i would want my archives to be
other colleges wanted
well i have to think i have to think
about that will they be available for
people to see something they must be yes
because you know everything that's in my
books i mean
well just because i've been working with
it i'm sure i'm not exaggerating if i
say i have hundreds when i take the
notebooks i take
you know in hand but my rule is
uh
and very seldom broken i have to say
is i'm i come home and transcribe those
notes on my typewriter before i go to
bed because i don't
want to
have an interval of sleep i want to
remember their reactions because i put
the reactions the facial expressions in
my notes
and if i miss you know i want to
remember turns of phrase that i might
not have put it down
i've never counted how many you know for
this book alone
i've done over a thousand interviews
if you looked at my files the type
transcripts of the notes
i mean are just
they're thousands of pages
um
and they duplicate them oh sure i put
them in different places so that if
there was ever a fire in my office there
would be other
words oh yes
because they contain i have to say brian
a lot i mean only you know you say what
proportion of them gets into your books
you know
tiny
and yet you want people to know this
other stuff i mean i've got things and
you know for other you can approach
lyndon johnson other aspects of him that
i haven't been able to go into other
things that he did say in the senate
and you want people to have all this
information and you're constantly saying
and these people are dying you know
now with horus busby you know
i mean i don't know how many interviews
i had with busby i mean i interviewed
him
well i think i say in the back of the
book i don't remember how many typed you
know some of these interviews went on
all day you know in washington
um
in addition to that
he would call me with information you
know and he knew he was giving me
information that no one else possessed
he had a stroke
his children who are devoted to him as
they should be is quite a wonderful very
iconoclastic man
moved him out to california so they
could take care of him
and he would call me you know
and then he learned to had another
stroke i believe but he went blind
but he had touched type because he had
been a reporter once so he used to type
me these letters with information with
stories anecdotes in them
the only reason you knew he was blind
was that sometimes the line would run
off the page and uh
you know he didn't know that
then he'd sign it with this
huge wavering bee
and you know near the end
you know it was very important to him
did he get all these stories and
anecdotes uh
out to me or whatever
his last letter to me
is something like
was in the hospital again for two days
really bad time
didn't know i'd come out all i could
think of was
now bob will have no one to tell him
about the vice presidency
so he says i'm better now
i i don't know that he really believed
that because he saw in the letter with a
word he had never used before farewell
and a little while later he was dead so
you feel that these interviews that you
have obtained
are sort of sacred
and we're never going i mean there will
be other biographies of lyndon johnson
and whoever does them or there will be
other things on vietnam the other things
in american history
and you really feel
you have to have these in a place where
they're not you know it's easy to give
them to a library you have to make sure
the library treats them in a way where
the people have access to it because i
myself have so much trouble you know
sometimes going to send an aina has
trouble going to the papers of a senator
or something they really it's not easy
to
make a collection of things so people
can find what's in it it happens to be
very hard very expensive and very time
consuming so i have to find the right
place we're talking about bob carroll's
brand new book called master of the
senate it'll be in your book stores on
april the 23rd this is his first
interview about this new book we go to
mesa arizona thank you for waiting go
ahead please mr carroll great honor to
be speaking with you
books they're immensely wonderful very
well written i'm from texas myself and
uh without out the lbj ranch last fall i
don't recall seeing either means of
ascent or path to power but uh certainly
you are very well known
a couple of couple of thoughts here you
didn't interview coke stevenson
and i'd like for you to share your
thoughts about that also a little bit of
the contrast between mr stevenson you
touched on it already a little bit but
if you go a little bit more in depth
about his character and his approach to
political campaigns as opposed to lbj
and then lastly i'd like to get your
thoughts during lbj's final days what
his views were on nixon whether they had
changed on i think at one time he had
referred to nixon as the the chronic
campaigner uh but just that his chain
did his thoughts at all change on on his
predecessor i mean it is a fellow who
followed him uh
i'm going to
say that i'm still working on his final
days which is certainly poignant and his
views to nixon so i'm going to take a
pass on that i've spoken you know
earlier in this program about the
difference between coke stevenson's
campaigning
and lyndon johnson's campaigning the old
campaigning of stevenson driving from
time town to town and johnson with the
media campaigning of course johnson
campaigned in a helicopter during this
that's coke stevenson the cowboy
governor
you really felt you know people have
asked why i spent so much time going
into the legend of coke stevenson
because it was necessary to show how
strong this legend was and the hold it
had on the people of texas his
the reverence that they had for coke
stevenson in order to show the power of
media politics negative campaigning if
you want
it can destroy anything
however conservative or racist coke
stevenson may have been
he was a hero
to the voters of texas so for someone to
come along a congressman
and defeat him
you have you know one way to show the
power of something whenever i see people
writing about the power of negative
campaigning and how strong it is which
we're coming to appreciate now i say
uh it was less appreciated than
uh 1989 or 90 it was some appreciated
but
the best way to show the the power of
something is to show it the contrast
when you have the ultimate contrast what
more could be a contrast than a guy who
will not use media campaign who draws
from town to town campaigns as an
individual and a guy who's buying all
this radio time and using polling modern
polling techniques modern media
techniques i said i first have to show
what coke stevenson was in order to show
how lyndon johnson destroyed that here's
a photograph from 1941 in your path to
power book of london johnson you
describe him
in your book
i mean you talk about the ears
the hands
what struck you as being the most
prominent part of london johnson
physically
well
something that came from within him but
became physical brian it's i hope i
described him right this way in the book
because you know everyone talks about
johnson how he he was huge of course he
was almost six foot four he had him his
hands were huge even for his size and
his arms were very long even for his
size
and of course he had a face that was he
had a very prominent nose very prominent
chin these huge ears
blazing eyes everybody who talks about
lyndon johnson talks about his eyes but
the thing that got me in the senate they
talk about how he was a persuader you
know we all know how he would put his
hand around you grab your lapel you know
punch in the chest with his forefinger
if you weren't agreeing with him right
it was what was inside him the passions
and the emotions the beliefs and desires
the ambition and compassion that he had
that was so strong that made that thing
it was like the body big as it was
couldn't contain it and it made the
finger j about it and made this blaze
out of his eyes
so that's what i tried to portray in
this book i'm not sure that i did it
adequately oxnard california you're on
the air
mr caro it's such a pleasure to speak
with you thanks i would like to talk
about power brokers and robert moses i'm
a displaced new yorker okay
i read the book and i every day i
reported to my friends my family and my
neighbors the uh one in sob he was every
night i would read and my mouth would
just drop how he got away with things
also
how he destroyed people same as you just
talked about lbj destroying people
i also want to reminisce about you said
about all the collecting of the tolls i
remember when the belt parkway uh the
valley stream toll booth was put up
and then i think it's is it the only
toll booth in the world that was taken
down
because it's gone i don't know
but it's i was surprised at that having
grown up um and going out to long island
and jones beach was such a big thing
but thank you for your books and could
you please talk about mr moses and how
he destroyed people and the
overt power that he the corruption of
the power how he started off as such a
reformer and how he just went downhill
it was thank you so much for that book
could i ask you to tell the story in
conjunction with this call of the
central park
parking lot at tavern on the green sure
it was another robert moses you know he
wanted every to him the automobile was
paramount everything should be
sacrificed to the automobile there was
this beautiful playground i actually can
see it from my window when i shave in
the morning
that was on on 67th street uh i live on
69th street in central park
and moses was determined to turn it into
a parking lot and the mother is on 67th
street
this was way back before they had uh
picketing
as we know it today and they wheeled
their baby carriages in and in front of
the build bulldozers and stopped him and
it was really one of the first times
that he was stopped
here's a picture of him you see a lot
what is this one
uh that's a picture of robert moses yeah
he's standing on a beam and that's the
that's robert moses and if you turn the
page you'll see the guy the guy i wrote
about or that's robert that's the robert
moses i wrote about and i think
uh that
that picture
for somebody tuning in and have never
heard of robert moses quick capsule of
who he was sure you draw you fly it's
the easiest way to do it for people who
never lived in new york you fly into new
york let's say you're coming in uh to
laguardia so you're playing uh turns
over connecticut for the approach and
you you uh pass the throgs neck bridge
robert moses built that then you pass
the bronx white stone bridge robert
moses built that then you fly over the
henry hudson bridge and turn around
robert moses built out and then you come
back over the tri bro bridge robert
moses built that if you're flying into
uh
kennedy you see the verrazano bridge
robert moses built that the cross bay
boulevard bridge the marine parkway
boulevard bridge robert moses built that
he built every major bridge built in new
york uh in the last three quarters of a
century he built uh you'd look down and
you see the the city streets the grid of
the streets but slashing across them are
these big straight
uh gray lines
and uh those are the expressways and the
parkways
with this with one exception the east
river drive every one of those miles
every one of those roads was built by
robert moses he built 672 miles of
expressways and parkways every park in
the city he either created or recreated
shaped or reshaped 40 000 new acres of
parks in new york he held power for 44
years almost half a century in new york
and he had and in the fields in which he
chose to exercise it which was the
fields which shaped the city forever
or for centuries let's be more accurate
he had more power than any mayor or any
governor any mayor or governor combined
and he was never elected to anything
robert moses is the subject of robert
carroll's first book called the power
broker came out in 1974.
since then he's had three books
including the new one we're talking
about today called master of the senate
the first lyndon johnson book came out
in what year
uh 1980
1982
the second one means 1990.
and this was the third one i remember
when i interviewed in 1990
you said that the book master of the
senate would be out in two years
sorry that you remember that and here we
are in 2002
any guess as to when your book on the
presidency will be up
well i don't want you coming back
in the face again i hope this will be a
lot faster because as i say i've done a
lot of the interviewing and a lot of the
work already san diego thanks for
waiting
yeah hi uh brian uh my question mr
carroll your books are outstanding uh i
have a question about huey long did lbj
ever express an opinion on senator long
and do you see a lot of similarities
between those men and i have a follow-up
question if you will okay you know uh
lyndon johnson used to say that when he
was a young congressional assistant he'd
go
and sit in the senate gallery to watch
ue long speak
uh he often compared himself to ue long
i myself i'm not sure that
comparison really holds in too many ways
what's your follow-up question okay the
question is um uh well two actually do
you like lbj after doing these histories
and also that the corruption american
elections that you talked about in the
senate is that pervasive or
thank you i'm sorry the sir i didn't i
didn't understand the last question
i didn't hear it and i apologize let's
go on to portland maine portland go
ahead please you're on the air yes one
of the questions i wanted to ask is how
did lyndon johnson maintain his
relationship with j edgar hoover when
mccarthyism came up there because they
had such a close relationship or he
cultivated jay go over as part of his
like he did with the senate majority
leaders and with the speaker of the
house
and the second part of it is
if you get into the civil rights there
of where the votes were traded off to to
get the final passage there who had to
be compromised into
switching votes to get that thing done
can i ask you to talk about hell's
canyon at that point on the civil rights
bill sure
about the first part i'm going to give
the same answer that j edgar hoover and
lyndon johnson i'm not done with the
work yet so i i don't know what to say
on that but the trading of votes to get
this first civil rights bill in 1950 you
have to understand
no civil rights bill had passed the
senate since the end of reconstruction
since 1875. for 82 years every civil
rights bill that came up in the senate
had been
killed by the south now in 1957 the
south had never been in a more uh in a
stronger position as i said i hope
earlier in the program there were 15
standing committees in the senate the
southerners controlled eight of the most
powerful and their allies controlled
another another one and two their power
seemed just about invincible in the
senate
uh
to get this bill passed one thing
johnson has to do is to try and proceed
this is
hard to sum this up um
johnson has to have an incredible blend
of his
really savage determination to get it
done it is going to be passed
uh
a grasp on the floor of instantaneous
that you know in legislation when you're
having a debate on the floor and things
are flying back and forth and people's
opinions are changing as they sometimes
do change in the senate
then you have to have the genius to
grasp that moment i mean that's a that's
like a that's like a battlefield genius
and lyndon johnson had that but then you
have to have and this is what brian
is asking me about
you have to have something more you have
to have the genius not of just of a
battlefield tactician but of a national
strategist and lyndon johnson could see
the senate in terms of a whole country
and that is basically one of the key
reasons that this 1957 civil rights bill
gets passed
tough to sum this up the south is afraid
to go forward with the bill because it's
gotten no allies
so we can stop the bill absolutely by
using a filibuster which is never going
to be broken at this point in history
johnson has to get bring some allies to
their side he sees that possible allies
are from the mountain states the rocky
mountain states oregon and north uh and
washington the states of the pacific
northwest if only he can find a way to
bring these two groups together and then
i wrote in the book he found the way
it wasn't in the south
it wasn't in the appalachians which were
next to the south it wasn't in the great
plains that stretch out from the the
appalachians it wasn't in the rockies it
was on the far side of the rockies it
was in a canyon called hell's canyon
the senators of the pacific northwest
wanted a federal dam in hell's canyon
they had never been able to get it
through
because among other reasons and this is
really a drastic oversimplification
the south had not wanted it because they
didn't like public power they wanted
private power
johnson persuades
the south
to give the northwest enough vote enough
votes
to approve the hell's canyon dam and in
return
the northwest gives the south
enough votes to give the south what it
wants so it can let this bill
move forward it's a stroke of sheer
genius i mean when you say who could
bring these two parts of the country so
different than philosophy so different
in interests together
that's what legislative genius is you
know we don't think of that genius in
the united states to us political genius
we think of is it's executive genius
it's presidential genius that's what's
written about
legislative genius is something very
different that's what this book is about
this is about a different kind of genius
it's about
brokering about compromises about making
deals
not about leading a country with oratory
and inspiring them
uh england has a million biographies or
at least a hundred
because it's it's got a parliamentary
system and it's leaders of parliamentary
leaders gladstone and israeli they're
great biographies on gladstone and
israeli and pit and peel etc
we
in in my opinion have a very inadequate
understanding
of what legislative genius is and that
it's just as important in a democracy
as executive genius
and
there are times
when we can see this i said earlier that
i try and show things by using the life
of a man rather than by giving a lecture
if you study lyndon johnson's career in
the senate in my opinion you are seeing
legislative leadership and in the case
of something like hell's canyon
legislative genius
here is what the book looks like it's
1167 pages long can you compartmentalize
it we know that you write a lot about
the civil rights bill in 1957.
the first couple hundred pages a lot of
discussion about richard russell and the
senate itself right talk about hubert
humphrey in the book what else what
other major chunks well the other major
chunk is lyndon johnson i mean this guy
you know when he's young i mean you have
this guy
swaggering and the house of
representatives he's rushing through the
halls pushing through the halls he wears
these unbelievable you know his weight
went up and down uh
in this book alone his weight went
between 175 and i think 225
and i think he went up to 240 later um
that's quite a picture that he's wearing
a fat max tie that's what they called
him in texas then but it's also by the
way you look right here it's a countess
maritime
which is
a very expensive time i i didn't i
didn't realize it was but you are those
those are elephants or i don't know what
they were right there is this
well
uh
and he wanted because his weight went up
and down and he wanted to conceal it
what he would do is have his his suit
jackets and his pants cut so big so when
his weight was at a lower level they
would flap around you know the first
time someone said to me you know when he
would walk around his jackets would
flare out if he turned around they'd
flare out i didn't believe that you know
but it turns out
to be true
and he had these mannerisms about him
he's a titanic figure as an individual
dallas texas and we've got about an hour
to go with robert carroll go ahead
please thanks c fan for the opportunity
to talk to mr cairo and uh what a really
thank him for some education he's
provided
those of us interested in johnson if i
could just reel off a couple of things
about johnson's scandals
previous students becoming president
specifically
to your point about the library and
archives there's a clint peeples a texas
ranger
gave his archives to dallas public
library and if you go there and look for
it you won't find it who has it you know
maybe a judge in texas with the initials
bs who knows but
my point is is the clint peoples
investigated a murder of a man named
henry marshall you might be aware of and
it all ties into the cotton allotment
scandal some billy assault estus
activities
and for years clint peoples at the
behest of the marshall family stayed on
this doggedly and pursued who he thought
was guilty of this murder and ultimately
this led to a grand jury indictment that
named cliff carter lyndon johnson
malcolm wallace as being
party and co-conspirators in the death
of henry marshall now had these men been
alive at the time they would have faced
grand jury indictment in that county now
that's
one of many scandals
that linked to johnson that were
investigated by congress which i'm under
the impression have these investigations
have been sealed by johnson's uh you
know people and we're not even allowed
to view what congress found out about
johnson now i don't know if that's true
or not let me ask robert care if it is
is it true well i i'm not aware uh i
that's another thing that i'm going to
say i'm not done looking into i'm not
aware
that
lyndon johnson was ever indicted as a
conspirator into the murder of henry
marshall i i'm not aware of that
uh i'm also not aware
that congress investigated that
um
certainly the scandal that you're
talking about is one of these huge
scandals the billy soles this henry
marshall scandal that
has to be at least referred to and going
into at least to some extent in my
latest volume and lyndon johnson because
it's a it's a
a part of
his story
but it's not something i've looked into
yet
we ask you to bring some personal
pictures along with you and i have here
a scrapbook that says master of the
senate 2002. i'm just going to open it
up and ask you to comment on a picture
or two in here this is your wife aina
how when was that picture taken
i'm not sure in the last couple of years
that's me and einer einer is the whole
team a wonderful writer who booked the
road from the path now that c a lot of
people don't like my books but everybody
likes hers and
she's a great
researcher where's this picture from
that's me age something
you don't remember what age no
you remember what age this was taking
well i do sort of remember that that's
about the i because i remember where'd
you live uh we lived on central park
west my mother got sick in that year i
always think i was five years old
mentioned horace mann school earlier
this is i think from horse man i'm in
the middle i'm the editor of the horace
mann record on my right is gerald jonas
who's the editor of the horace mannequin
the yearbook and on my left is michael
cooper who in my memory possibly stated
is is was the editor of the
literary magazine so that the three
editors on the other side is this photo
what year
that year was 1956.
that is actually the moment
this is a rare photo this is the very
moment that i first met my wife aina it
was at a dance at princeton it was
called the prince tiger dance i think my
title was managing editor or something
in the daily princetonian which ran the
dance
and i therefore i was sort of the mc
and a photographer came up to take my
picture
and i had noticed this beautiful
young woman
dancing with somebody else right and i
had been eyeing her all evening so when
the photographer said i
came up to take the picture i said why
don't i take it with someone else for
example her
the photographer brought her up
and we made our acquaintance where is
this picture
that's on our honeymoon that's the
broadmoor hotel in colorado that's a
long time ago how long did you two date
before you married uh
i guess about two years or so
this picture with nelson rockefeller
right that's an interesting picture when
i was a reporter you see the expression
on the governor's face is somewhat less
than enthusiastic
i had done this series of investigative
articles for newsday the governor had a
bill had been passed and the governor
was signing it
ostensibly because it would clear up the
scandal
um
he invited me to the office
i was saying at this moment but the bill
isn't really going to work and you can
see the expression on the governor's
face there's a color photo from what
year is this
well i don't know when my son would have
been i guess uh six or seven so we're we
would be talking like in the nine uh
1965 and he is 44 years old did you say
the other yeah you're 6433. you're 66
yes graduated from princeton in 1957.
correct have written four books
yeah you still do you still get up every
day and
hard charge on this subject of lyndon
i don't know
if horror george is applicable
today as you've always been yeah it's
sort of thrilling
why why still well because uh for a lot
of reasons one thing he never stops
being fascinating and new but more to
the point you know you didn't once they
asked me on a previous interview and i
thought it was the best question i mean
why do you write about these and i've
never wanted to write about a lyndon
johnson or robert moses just to tell the
story of a great man brian i'm
interested in political power and using
the life and you are going to stop
talking i just wanted to ask you who
this was that's my editor bob godley
this book is dedicated to him as well as
to aina the dedication says to buy to
robert gottlieb
30 years
four books
thanks that's the day the first copy of
the power broker came in out of which he
and i had to cut
in 350 000 words
and i didn't mean to interrupt you you
were talking about you really interested
in power oh so
what what at what moment did you pick
london johnson i picked well i picked
him long before i started on him because
i was a reporter i got more and more
interested in political power
i discovered that i really didn't have
any understanding of it and as far as
urban power in new york state was
concerned so much of it revolved around
this man robert moses we had been taught
that in a democracy power comes from a
ballot box from being elected he was
this guy was never elected anything and
he had more power in his fields than
anybody else i said before more than any
governor or mayor combined so i did the
power broker not primarily to tell the
life of robert moses but to tell
to to try to find out because i didn't
know and then to try to explain where he
got the power and i by doing that i felt
i was coming close not to what we're
taught in textbooks but to the real raw
essence of what urban political power is
not just in america but in all the
cities
of the united states in the 20th century
now all the time we were doing this book
we were broke i just wanted to try to
finish this book and get back to a
salary job i never thought i'd be able
to do another book but i realized that
i'd like to do the same thing with
national power and of all the
politicians in the second half of the
century which was the century that i
knew
lyndon johnson was the guy who
understood it best and you ask why i'm
all excited because
it was thrilling to learn about the hill
country to have to move a city boy like
me
up to the edge of the hill country and
spend three years trying to learn it
that's thrilling to do that then it was
thrilling to learn about a stolen
election i said i'm going to show you
people keep talking about stolen
elections i'm going to show america what
a stolen election is by looking at one
stolen election
and
this book
i really have to say i've spent 12 years
trying to learn
the world of the united states senate of
the 1950s which is
very different from the senate of today
it was just great i mean there are
moments in this you know that
on my desk because i'm putting my files
away and i just came
across a fax from richard baker the
senate librarian and on the front of it
says bob we got lucky here it is well
what it is is a list of the
subcommittees of the various and
standing committees
i think it's in 1953
because i had come to realize from
talking from all these administrative
aides and other senate aides
that
a lot of the southerners power a lot of
power in the center was exercised not
just through appropriations committees
say but through the subcommittees of
appropriations these subcommittees
sometimes only had five people or seven
people no one knew what they were doing
i wanted a show and someone said to me
if you look at these subcommittees
you'll see all the key ones the
southerners made sure that they were the
they had the casting votes if it was a
seven-member committee that they they
were their allies would have four votes
every time so
well i wanted to write about that but i
couldn't do it if i didn't have the uh
the membership of the subcommittees and
i was told we don't have that no one
lists the members you know after all
this time in the subcommittee
but once again because the senate
historian dick baker and his associate
story don ritchie wouldn't stop working
for me i mean it's a very selfless thing
i mean i can never express my gratitude
to them adequately they found it i
forget they found them in some senate
payroll things that some place where you
wouldn't expect to find it so it's
thrilling to me and there's a whole
chapter about london johnson's
chairmanship of the preparedness
subcommittee when he dealt with the
grand war right just like truman had
dealt with world war ii right i mean
that's you talk about things that i mean
someone would say how can you write
about i don't know how many pages i
spend in that book but it's a lot of on
on a subcommittee because this
subcommittee was the instrument the
first instrument in which lyndon johnson
raised himself out of the crowd it's a
it's
it's how you use a subcommittee with
genius some more personal pictures and
uh this is what year would you say
this was last year in france einar and i
go to france
every summer and this is our apartment
there or the park we had there
that's just that that's a relaxed time
for me it's when ina works very hard on
her books and we're going to go back to
phones in just a second but i keep
saying we're going to get to the hubert
humphrey tape this is a tape from 1964.
lyndon johnson is president ewing
humphries in the senate okay and i just
want to play this so you can get a sense
of what their relationship was at least
on these oval office conversations right
let's go with the tape
i don't believe you ought to be quoting
me on what i'm ready to do on these
amendments just tell what you all are
doing mr president that was not my quote
and i'm very sorry saw all the tickers
though and they're raising hell about it
and
i just uh was asked in the senate and i
said now the president
don't quote me unless you talk to me
unless you know i won't say it because
i can say it down here and i've been
saying that every press conference since
i came in here and they would like very
very much to say i weakened the bill and
i'm not gonna
that's not my position i'm against any
amendment it's gonna be against them
right up till i sign them now you all
can take whatever you want to
do the attorney general that's what i
said here this morning i said the
president the united states wants the
house bill
and i set the president united
our job and the senate is to legislate
the president the united states is not
going to tell us what to do
and that he's a man a reasonable man and
we will do what we are required to do
here and then the president will have to
decide what he wants that's good that's
the thing to do and that's the way to
handle it
this is just a brief excerpt just from
the oval office tapes hubert humphrey
did not know he was being taped lyndon
johnson did of course what did you hear
there
the voice of a man in command
and um
that's the tone johnson then of course
that is the tone with which he spoke to
humphrey as vice president by the way
next week they're going to release
another 40 hours of tapes we carry them
every saturday afternoon on our radio
station and on the web what do you think
of this whole
audio tape released by the johnson
library i'm not going to answer that i'm
going to write about that
in your next book
i'm i'm or i might write something
separately about that because you know
something we don't know i didn't say
that i just i just said that i'm going
to discuss it austin texas you're on
with robert carroll go ahead please hi
um i grew up in san antonio and my
family is from
the south texas area three rivers and
rio grande city
and the longoria story just affected me
very personally i just wanted to um
thank you very much for um exposing that
it's just um
very hard to get that kind of historical
um accuracy in those stories
and i wanted to ask you um
how difficult was it um to research um
all of the interactions that went on
between hector garcia and the funeral
home and um because it is so local but
it was had such a national um impact and
um anyway i just really love your books
why does this mean so much to you can
you explain to the rest of the country
yeah that um that history it's so
shrouded and those people are so um
amazingly dispossessed they have no
voice um
and i'm sorry um
they don't have
um a voice and and the poverty and in
those areas is so striking
um and the the um
the um
the patriotism of that area and um what
do they um contribute as citizens it's
just really profound i mean they're just
a very
um um loyal and hard-working people and
they have never really had um a voice
and they've never really had um access
to uh higher education um you know to to
a place um at the table and
okay
thank you i didn't mean to cut you off i
want to get
uh mr carroll's
point of view on the longoria story what
was it i'm so glad that uh
you called about that um of course
uh for those of you who don't know it
this occurred just about a week after
johnson get got to the center the mec a
mexican-american soldier who had been
killed in the philippines during the war
his body is now being returned for
burial and his
widow wants the body buried in uh three
rivers in in his hometown and the three
rivers funeral director refuses because
he says the whites won't like it if the
mexicans mexican americans use the white
chapel
and the widow goes to hector garcia who
is the founder of the mexican-american
gi forum
and garcia sends off 17 telegrams to 17
representatives and senators and the
president
one of them goes to lyndon johnson's
office now lyndon johnson
had both the compassion and the genius
to make that compassion meaningful
this telegram comes into his office we
see it in the files it's received at 8
49
it's tuesday morning
can't re neither john connolly or walter
jenkins remembers which ones opens but
they're both standing there when lyndon
johnson walks in he takes the telegram
he looks at him and he says the exact
right thing by god will bury him at
arlington
and he arranges for
longoria's body to be
given a hero's burial
in arlington
now of course i think everything with
lyndon johnson
that wonderful part of it there is
another part of it when the anglo-rulers
of that area of your area you know the
rio grande valley and up to three rivers
who really controlled politics there and
who johnson needed when they become
infuriated at him for this
if you read in the book
then john conley said we began to
backtrack and the backtracking was an
example of johnson's uh kindly says he
if i have this quote correct i think i
do
linda never believed in being a dead
hero but he always knew what to do
that's what i mean
when i say that power always reveals
when he gets the power the compassion is
revealed at last
bethel maine you're on the air mr
carroll uh three quick questions on your
uh non-relationship with the surviving
members of the johnson johnson family uh
one would it be safe to assume that's in
spite of efforts that you made both with
lady bird and linda to establish some
kind of communication oh sure mrs
johnson uh spent a lot of time with me
in the early years of the book i think
we had seven interviews very long
interviews very helpful interviews
they were not ended i have to say
because of anything i wrote
because they ended they were cut off
long before anything i wrote
appeared
i've never you know
known why
sometimes i think they suddenly realized
that someone was really looking into all
these stories about lyndon johnson
because so many of the stories about his
youth and his young political career
that had been told in every biography
over and over again
when someone looked into them
weren't true
has jack fellaini talk to you no
will he oh i doubt it you ever ask him
well he's attacked me publicly you know
does bill moyers ever talk to you uh no
he hasn't but i haven't i asked him to
and i hope he will anybody else that
refuses moyers has moyes hasn't entered
my you know
until he becomes president anybody else
that uh refused to talk to you
uh
there are others i have to but i i i
i'm not remembering off the top of my
head very much
i know mcpherson has refused to talk to
me uh
and others but you know like when you
say in the senate career who were the
people who worked in johnson's office
the back desks were the most important
were connolly and busby they both talked
to me all i wanted
walter jenkins and then george reedy
mary rather
mary louise glass young every one of
them talk to me you know with some of
them i had as i said dozens of
interviews uh i list in the sources you
know maybe 20 or 25 johnson people who
so while you would like to have these
other
interviews and they would certainly add
something i think
you have quite a bit anyway san diego
thank you for waiting
hi my question is
mr carrow do you think most elections in
america are clean or
are the the things that happened in 1948
pervasive thank you uh that's a that's a
terrific question you know and i just
i'm going to take one minute to say you
know we're appearing in a program here
and i'm appearing with brian lamb and as
i hear these questions and i think
where else in america do you get a
chance you know if you're an author
you're lucky if they give you six or
seven minutes
to talk about something where else do
you get to examine these things at such
depth i'm being given three hours here
you know if i can't explain myself in
three hours i don't have anything to
explain it's really all due to brian
lamb and i really do thank you uh this
is what should have been done for books
it's what's being done now and uh
everyone who cares about books in
america should care about what you've
done for them anyway i'm done
complimenting you your question is is
terrific i'm not an expert on how
pervasive stolen election are in america
but this
obviously they are not rare
uh people have criticized me for in the
second volume spending so much time and
talking about how lyndon johnson
about
about how lit i
i think they're gesturing me that i'm
looking in the wrong place where do you
want me to look
oh sorry
uh people have criticized me about uh
talking about lyndon johnson
how he stole this election in such
detail they say you know if you looked
at any uh campaign or whatever wouldn't
you find sort of the same things well my
answer to that is if it is pervasive if
you would find it so pervasively in
american politics that's not a reason
not to write about it if i'm interested
in political power and i'm trying to
explain political power that's a reason
to write about it to examine it in all
the detail that you possibly can my
vehicle for doing that is the life of
lyndon johnson this is his stolen
election
this is an election that's very
significant because
whatever the truth about the bush gore
contest which i don't pretend to know
um
widespread things were going on
whichever side
this was not lyndon johnson did not
steal just the 202 votes that we learned
about for so many years when they were
found found as in quote six days after
the election by 202 voters who went to
the polls in alphabetical order right he
stole tens of thousands of votes and i
documented that nobody can ever again
in my opinion
be in doubt as to whether lyndon johnson
stole his way into the united states
senate so when you say
that is the extent of what can be done
with a stolen election a stateward
election that's something that a lot of
political scientists and a lot of
historians should be looking at
in detail
anyway i'm done with that los angeles
for robert carroll hi thank you uh
actually i wanted to ask you one thing
you've talked about a lot of things uh
so far today one thing i was wanted to
catch you mentioned a speech that lasted
eight minutes but it was the most
exciting speech you've ever heard yes
who uh
who gave that speech sir hubert humphrey
gave it at the 1948 democratic
convention he uh they it was a the
convention was going to
pass yet another
meaningless civil rights plank they told
him he was told if he made a speech
demanding a strong plank his career
would be ended he decided to give the
speech anyway
i can still see him on this videotape as
he's giving it his his hand is up his
head is back it only lasts eight minutes
i think
there were only 43 sentences
and i said before he was halfway through
the audience was cheering
everyone
hubert humphrey had always had a voice
that could bring people to their feet
marching and the delegates came to their
feet now
san diego next go ahead please yeah hi
mr carroll thank you very much and hi
brian hi um i just wanted to uh say i
was really struck by your comment
earlier about uh connolly saying that
johnson represented the new politics and
um given that you know there seemed to
be with the timing of your book a lot of
uh superficial similarities with the
current president being from texas so
having the war etc
i'd like mr caro to kind of if he could
comment on comparing and contrasting
what's similar what's changed and
especially in light of the
current president's move to seal
presidential papers
well uh i'm not prepared to talk about
similarities or differences between
lyndon johnson and our present president
because i don't
i've sort of been in my own world
finishing this book
and i don't think i've thought that
through enough
the other question about the access to
presidential papers which has not
the restriction of the access to
presidential papers which has not
received enough attention in this
country
nothing could be more serious
there is no reason
for the public papers of of the highest
public official in the united states
to be denied to the public of the united
states you can talk about that and
analyze it uh
and lawyers can go back and forth but
that is the principle
philadelphia go ahead please thank you
for having me mr lam uh your program is
outstanding as always and mr carroll
your books have uh uh have been just
simply fascinating and i just bought it
uh today
on amazon looking forward to getting it
and one topic that i thought you might
be addressing the book i was curious
about maybe you can comment on i don't
think anyone's asked you about it today
is the role of the staff
aide bobby baker
in johnson's mastery of the senate i was
hoping he'd talk a little bit about that
about how that helped him or how bobby
baker
was
a colleague and an ally in the senator's
rise to mastery of the senate and then
also after that if you might be able to
comment on how the criticisms of your
first two books in particular the second
book and not just by johnson loyalists
how that affected
uh the words you chose and the tone of
this most recent book here's a picture
thank you here's a picture in the new
book of bobby baker and lyndon johnson
well
to take the end of your question first
the criticism of the book not just by
johnson loyalists but by critics
i suppose you're aware
that both of these books
i don't usually say this but since you
asked the question in that way we've
voted the best non-fiction book of the
year by the national book critics circle
which is about 700 of the most
influential critics
in the country
so you could hardly say that
the critical reception of the book
has been
hostile or that the criticism has been
that has been mostly criticism
uh bobby baker is one of the johnson
people who would not talk to me
um
nonetheless he didn't talk at all no
nonetheless uh
we uh there's quite a bit of bobby baker
in this book because there were a lot of
memorandums
from him in the johnson library
and
he is a figure in the he is a figure in
the book
you have a chapter in this book
i'm trying to find it i think it's
titled 30th place yes
we have some video of 49 21 30th place
oh great
what's so important about this house
well that's linda johnson's home during
this entire period in washington yes
it's a it's a
it's a
house of which you find many houses like
that in washington nothing spectacular
about it except the man who lived in it
the thing that got me about it is
many evenings in that neighborhood where
many nights three or four o'clock in the
morning when there was only one light on
it was always always a light
in a bedroom of this house because
lyndon johnson wouldn't be sleeping he'd
be working to bend the senate to his
will and did he is this a house did sam
rayburn and the richard russells go to
this house absolutely
on sundays you know they call them
linden's two daddies and therefore he
didn't want them to meet each other too
often so that he could see they could
each see how he acted to the other daddy
luckily i said there were two meals on
sunday
and russell would come for
lunch and rayburn would come for dinner
here's a photo in the book of london
johnson at the democratic policy
committee is this george reedy sitting
right next to him there uh yes
and anybody else in there that looks
familiar to you right off hand uh i
can't quite no they're not i can't quite
see let's go to romeo
romeo michigan you're on the air good
morning gentlemen hi um
i'm a wwe
two vet
1944.
out in southwest pacific i met lyndon
johnson i just he was with us captain of
our squadron which was flying around the
islands out there
i followed him quite closely so i'm
going to try to
try to get somebody across i'm looking
at a letter here dated september 22nd
1937 to mr prescott bush
59 wall street new york new york
it's about
their press i've looked at the letter of
the german american
cable company etc etc in regard to some
bonds it signs john foster dulles of
course john he was a lawyer then he john
dulles became secretary of state of
course his brother
head of the cia now the question is
george bush
uh 45 was a young officer in the navy
just getting out and that's about the
time uh probably a doubly was conceived
he was born 46
bush
after yale went to midland why suddenly
an easter establishment man goes into
midland texas
well it's the big uh oil connections uh
uh
side note yesterday the california
derby was won by a horse owned by a part
owner of will ferris who was bush's
ambassador to england caller what's the
question regarding lyndon johnson please
well
the i wonder if you could tell us about
the the yarborough bush campaign which
is pretty rough as i understand it i'm
gonna let you go is there any
relationship in this to uh i'm sorry
caller it's just off the topic and we
need to keep moving because time is
moving portland maine you're on the air
yes my name is george vincent i was
calling in and it's uh my impression
that without london johnson the united
states couldn't have gone into the last
third of this century segregated and
that that would be his greatest legacy
to american politics
well i think that um while i'm not
prepared to make a final conclusion on
that until i examine his presidency in
more depth at the moment i think that
there's no question
that
the advances in civil rights which began
in 1957 came to a climax and during his
presidency in 1964 and 65 and have
changed america however
unfortunately slow progress may be in
some areas would not have i mean johnson
was the moving figure i wrote in this
book
to me the most important thing is voting
rights because what johnson saw was
everything else would come
as long as he could give
black americans
the right to vote and i wrote it was
abraham lincoln
who freed the slaves
but it was lyndon johnson who took them
by the hand
led them into their voting booth
placed their hands on the lever that
gave them control over their own destiny
and made them once and forever a part of
american political life so i think you
might well be right
next call is peoria illinois go ahead
please hello uh mr carroll i
must
compliment you the way i did 17 years
ago when i had the distinct pleasure of
spending about two hours with you
when i took you from the dallas fort
worth airport to waco texas where you
were speaking at a public library
function
and at that time i told you that one of
the most wonderful pieces of social
history i'd ever written a pardon me i'd
ever read
was your chapter on the sad irons in
your first book
so regardless of how people feel about
lyndon johnson they should try to get
that book because that piece of writing
was a masterpiece on what it was like to
live in texas before air conditioning
the question i have for you is one i
asked you in the car
and i think you kind of sidestepped it
because you didn't want to give away the
farm so to speak but i'm going to make
you answer it now in front of everybody
when you write a controversial book like
your first book
and you sort of give away your position
on how you feel about these
controversial issues on johnson how then
do you relate to people like lady bird
and certainly these people who have
given their life away to mr johnson uh
when you try to talk to them later when
you write their your second book and
your third book and your fourth book
because certainly they aren't going to
be as objective to you toward you when
when they then see that you are on one
side of the fence or the other thanks
caller
well um
varies from person to person uh
in the case of the people who are most
important for example to this book i
think i've said this before
john connelly walter jenkins harris
busby george reedy
mary rather ken baloo many others that i
that i could name
they seem to fear whatever they thought
of the first two books
i'm not going to repeat the
complementary things they say and i'm
not going to try to remember other
things
that they say but they never stopped
working with me and helping me and
whatever to whatever detail and richness
the
johnson books have my johnson books have
i'm really indebted to the to the
members of his staff you know if you
talk about texas in the 1940s and 50s
perhaps the two
the three most single important people
to lyndon johnson were john connolly
edward clark the quote secret boss of
texas johnson's lawyer for 25 years as
principal lawyer for 25 years who i
mentioned before
and
i was going to say herman brown herman
brown died but george brown john
connolly and ed clark between the three
of them
there's not much you can't find out
about how texas politics really was and
they both were very they all three were
very helpful too i asked you this
question at the beginning of the program
and to try one more time what do you
think
and a reporter reading your book will
come up as the lead
new new information
in the newspaper stories once this book
comes to publication date
is there a lead i don't think there is
um
if i i mean their their sense i suppose
you could say they're sensational things
you know give me a one example of
something you destroyed three uh in 1949
before senator mccarthy had begun lyndon
johnson used mccarthy techniques to
destroy a leading liberal member
legal in those
another headline could be
johnson rose to power faster than anyone
in the history of the senate another
lead could be
lyndon johnson
set out and passed the first civil
rights spill since reconstruction in the
senate in which the south held most of
the power i mean i don't think
i have to say i don't think in terms of
stories i i never have
and i don't know the i mean maybe there
is a lead but i don't see it at this
moment wheaton maryland go ahead please
hello yeah you're on the air oh yes sir
in reference to lyndon johnson's a
residence
he purchased a house in pearl mesta in
spring valley he lived in that house
for quite a while him and lady bird and
the daughters i know because i was
pleased and we had to protect that uh
house until it was sold
and also he also lived near j edgar
hoover on garrison street before he
lived at this place like 30th place yeah
he lived over there then he bought the
house in spring valley which at the time
that he bought and he said he didn't
notice
anti-semit um
afro-americans and
arabic people i'm just not up to that
well they they could not be it was it
was in the leases that you could check
the leases uh at that time the leases
they could not buy and he said he'd do
nothing about it his wife said he knew
nothing about it and i don't know if
pearl mester knew anything about it but
he did live there and the place was a
beautiful house thanks caller thank you
you say you're not up to that no i'm not
is that something that would interest
you yes
what if they prohibited african
americans from living that well yes i
mean as again i don't think it's a
headline i don't know but i what i have
to say honestly is i haven't looked into
it yet we have a little more tape of
your wife aina
we talked with a little bit and we asked
her about what
i'm not sure this fits right exactly at
the point but ask her about
what she learned about you and the time
that you've worked together and been
married let's watch you i know
okay just a second he really uh made me
much more liberal than i am
than i was to begin with because being
born in new jersey which isn't
particular which was a little bit on the
corrupt side politically
you had a feeling towards government
that being born in new york city you
wouldn't have
um
and when he gave me this project for the
uh for johnson and the rural
electrification
it was the first time i could see how
government really could help people
and it made me
about almost as liberal as he is
we're going to just take a quick break
and we'll be back with for the final 15
minutes with robert carroll
in depth with robert carroll will
continue in a moment
now here are this week's 10 best-selling
non-fiction books from the new york
times number one is stupid white men by
filmmaker and author michael moore
premiering at number two report from
ground zero author and retired
firefighter dennis smith's account of
the attack on the world trade center and
the rescue efforts that followed
bias by former cbs reporter bernard
goldberg is third
david brock details his disillusionment
with the conservative movement at number
four blinded by the right
number five is kenneth timmerman's
critical biography shakedown exposing
the real jesse jackson
love greg and lauren a husband's day by
day account of his wife's remarkable
recovery by greg manning comes in at
number six
lauren manning suffered burns over 82
percent of her body in the world trade
center attack
one nation america remembers september
11 2001 from the editors of life
magazine is seventh
that's followed by driver number eight
the account of dale earnhardt jr's first
year on the nascar circuit
ninth is sacred contracts by caroline
miss
and at number 10 the death of the west
pat buchanan's look at the decline of
western civilization
for more information on the bestseller
list visit the new york times website at
nytimes.com and click on books
in report from ground zero dennis smith
an 18-year veteran of the new york city
fire department sets out to describe the
attack on the world trade center and the
subsequent rescue efforts
today on book tv mr smith recounts
stories of first-hand witnesses
including fathers looking for their sons
in the rubble brothers looking for
brothers and a husband and wife caught
separately in the collapse
he also details his own participation in
rescue and recovery efforts today at 3
pm eastern dennis smith's report from
ground zero debuting at number two on
this week's new york times bestseller
list
tonight on book notes author and
journalist leonard downey jr on the news
about the news american journalism in
peril
we can't just blame the audience for
things we can't just say they all they
don't want to see foreign news dan
rather told us he wasn't allowed to use
the word foreign on the air anymore
because it would be a turn off to his
audience well i just don't believe that
it seems to me that if you are
presenting serious news in an engaging
way people will pay attention to it if
you point out to them that when most of
their cars and appliances are made
overseas and when a number of american
jobs have gone overseas because of
what's happening to the world economy
there are ways to make international
news for example interesting and
important to people
book notes with leonard downey jr
tonight at eight o'clock eastern and
pacific on c-span
upcoming guests include ellen joan
pollock author of the pretender how
martin frankel fooled the financial
world and led the feds on one of the
most publicized manhunts in history on
april 14th
and on april 21st our guest is gordon
wood author of the american revolution a
history
book notes every sunday at 8pm eastern
end pacific on c-span
live next saturday on book tv the
organization of american historians
holds two panel discussions
first starting at 11 a.m eastern how to
write history vividly doris kearns
goodwin robert carrow and nell irvin
painter discuss the art of writing
colorful narrative
and then live at 3 30 p.m how historians
use presidential archives in doing
historical research with panelists kyron
skinner annalise anderson and martin
anderson
they'll discuss how they use
presidential papers to produce the book
they co-edited reagan in his own hand
collection of president reagan's
writings
next saturday the organization of
american historians live only on book tv
only on c-span 2.
for the last 2 hours and 45 minutes
we've been talking about this book brand
new in the stores on april the 23rd
called master of the senate the years of
lyndon johnson robert carroll is our
guest and here is a
email from
irene martinez
was the helen douglas you are referring
to a congresswoman and from what state
was she married to another person who
eventually became a congressman and then
a senator senator and if johnson was so
close to sam rayburn from the beginning
of his tenure in the house why did he
feel he would never go anywhere in the
house or never have any power in the
house was it because he was too close to
sam rayburn and couldn't feel he could
ever become speaker unless raven
resigned or died well excellent
questions helena hagan douglas was a
congressman from california she was
married to melvin douglas the actor the
sam rayburn story
in the house things go by seniority
and
very very s the house is a very big
organization 435 members johnson felt he
was just one of a crowd rayburn would
try to help him but rayburn really
couldn't because the rules of seniority
johnson once tried to get rayburn to get
him to leapfrog some other members of
the texas delegation and get on the
appropriations committee
and the man who johnson tried to
leapfrog george mayheim said but sam
would never do that he went by the rules
you write about the affair between
lyndon johnson and helen hegan douglas
we have some videotape of him talking to
her years later when he was in the white
house let's just listen to a little bit
of what she sounded like she was married
to melvin douglas the actor here's helen
gahegan douglas
i want you to go to my representative
with dr wright from fisk university to
liberia
uh for
the 100th anniversary of the relations
between the united states and liberia
and i'd like to go myself i told the
vice president i'd try to come but i
can't do it and it says saturday this
saturday yes this saturday what you
shouting about
that's four days longer than you usually
have oh linda
listen um
come on chicken now
[Applause]
so don't chicken on me yeah
this will be good for you i want you to
get back in the public eye a little bit
and i want you to
uh we're going to have to run against
nixon
i don't i i don't know
i don't know
uh
he is one of them but i don't believe so
no no no that's not the place he is
the library i believe is the first and
first african nation we recognize and
they're
they're some of our best friends yeah i
know and
you don't have to be gone three or four
days
from the lyndon johnson oval office
tapes with helen gahegan douglas they
stayed friends all those years yes and
horace busby talks about
how while johnson was vice president
he came over to johnson's home one day
and there they were by the swimming pool
holding hands and busby said the thing
about lyndon johnson this is busby's
quote mine would be somewhat more
complicated
he could have real and deep feelings for
more than one person at the same time
marin county california north of san
francisco you're on with robert carroll
go ahead please mr carol yes sir first
of all there's not enough complimentary
words for your work and uh so i'm not
going to waste everyone's time and i
apologize in advance for asking a a
selfish question but i'm gonna i
your work is so definitive that i don't
think that i can offer up a johnson
question that isn't going to be dealt
with or answered of any import so
forgive me for asking a selfless
question when your work on johnson is
finished
do you have an inkling of what uh what
you have in mind for us because i'm
looking forward to something that that
might come afterwards that you'll you'll
tackle with the same
excellent uh writing that you have in
the past thanks well thanks for all the
nice things you say i do in fact have
one more topic that i'd like to do in my
life i'm very superstitious about saying
what it is
so will you give me a pass on that is it
a person
i do things through biography yes and so
is it again about power yes it is but if
you say that urban that robert moses was
urban power and lyndon johnson is
national power
then you can think at least the kind of
power that i want to but you know
excuse me excuse me for pointing out
that you are 66 years old i mean let's
say you live to be 85 is there time for
all this that's why that that was
actually what i meant by superstitious
uh of course that's that's the real
question and it's one of the things that
really upsets you i mean even when you
worked on this book you know you keep
saying well what if i die you know and
as you finish each part of it like on
the seniority system and how the senate
had always stopped civil rights you say
well at least if i
die now
people will know that i've done that
then if you say
how johnson
rose to power you know and rich how
richard russell
uh
wielded the south you say well that's
done you know at least it's done
and then you're really happy
when you get to the end of the book you
know and i kept thinking you know
because i saved the civil rights for the
last third of this book i mean you're
one of my best readers you know i said
this is all going in one place and you
got to see it all come together i'm not
spreading it out doing it chronology i
mean you've got to have martin luther
king the great black leader but he can't
do it alone you need a white leader and
eisenhower isn't going to lead and no
one else is leading there is no
leadership in the calls of power people
who really have power someone has to
come everyone is saying the black black
americans need a gandhi well they have a
gandhi it's it's martin luther king but
black americans also need a gladstone or
an israeli otherwise this wasn't going
to come together so i said gee i really
want to do it that way because you have
to show the tides of history and the man
who could take those tides and bend them
in the way they should go in his way
and i was really happy when i finished
that so it's disregarding your next book
let's go to new york city go ahead
please you're on the air
uh i have a couple sort of uh strange
but very but very very honest
compliments that i that i that i want to
take first of all mr carrow is always
available in new york city to a variety
of organizations and speaks a lot and i
don't know if he knows that the joke in
the audience while he's
speaking is
among his readers is if he we wish that
he wasn't here but that he went up to
his office writing the the other
the other the other thing is that i act
it's a true story but 10 years ago this
month i had to eulogize my my best
friend who was a senior college
administrator and
i had that report on last conversation
it's very truant story and i now laugh
about it
and our last conversation was to me he
said that i've had a great life a great
family he died much much too young he
said and i'll be happy if i at least can
live to re read all the carro johnson
books
and uh those are really nice words thank
you and it meant a lot to let me just
quickly ask you though who are the three
or four living people who you're not
going to get to because they won't talk
to you
but who who would add you think
substantially to what the rest
to the
volumes that you have to finish thank
you new york well i think mrs johnson
is in a class by herself she would she
would add something to the books
that no one else could
i don't know that i'd put anyone else
really in that category because while
many people
say they were uni especially close to
lyndon johnson that's not the way lyndon
johnson uh operated
uh everyone was like if he was the
center there were a lot of spokes to the
wheel if you have most of the spokes as
i do
i don't know that of course you know i
certainly hope that people like
mr moyers will will speak to me
but
whether they do or not
i will go on with the books you quote uh
or you refer to leslie carpenter the
husband of liz carpenter
has she talked to you oh no she's always
attacking me i think she's closest to
mrs johnson and all this i think so
cops in maine you're on yes it's a
pleasure to speak with you um being
immersed in j
lbj i was wondering what do you think
his reaction would have been to the
world trade center attacks if he had
been watching that on television
interesting because you know we have a
we have something on a much smaller
scale which can tell us about his
reaction which was the uss pueblo
incident which of course is not
comparable in scope or horror to the
world trade center but again it was an
unexpected
uh
enemy
i call it an enemy provocation johnson
had this fierce temper but he could
reign it in
and calculate
he used to say something which is really
true
that i'm toughest i'm at my best when
the bullets are flying
i don't know what his reaction that
that's always a bad thing to ask me
because i'm dealing with a very
unpredictable guy but it would have been
a very thoughtful reason and knowing
lyndon johnson forceful response for
those of you who are not lyndon johnson
experts and haven't read mr carroll's
books and there are threes now out on
lyndon johnson i want to show you the
timeline of his life
he lived to be how old
64. 1930
well that's the wrong spot on this whole
thing that's where
you can see 35 the appointment director
of the national youth administration
elected the u.s house after the death of
representative buchanan 37 right
reelected to congress 38
next
40 was appointed lieutenant commander
u.s naval reserve how long was he in the
navy well he was in the navy several
years he was in combat for about uh a
matter of hours in 41 he lost for the
u.s senate how by how big
i don't i think about 5 000 votes 48 he
was elected right beat coach stevenson
by 87 was that in the primary no yes in
the democratic 51 elected majority whip
right and then elected minority leader
at age 44 was that the youngest ever
youngest ever 53 chairman of
preparedness investigating subcommittee
you're going to have to go to the book
to hear that story it's a couple of
pages at very least re-elected to u.s
senate
55 july suffered his first heart attack
57 passages of the civil rights bill and
60 nominated elected vice president and
then became president in 1963 signed the
civil rights bill in july of 64
dedicated the lbj library 71 died in 73.
you know we haven't said this and we are
running out of time this 57 civil rights
bill more than anything else did what
the 57
can i use one of lyndon johnson's
typically rather vulgar but accurate
phrases it broke the virginity the south
had no civil rights bill had ever passed
the center one of the things that
johnson said
was behind what johnson was thinking was
we have to show people that the senate
can pay us the civil rights bill that it
is possible there are a lot of tangible
reasons which i examine in the book and
there's one very intangible one which is
so many senators were afraid of the
southerners what they would do to them
in their committees that just once he
had to show that their power could be at
least modified kansas olathe kansas
you're next go ahead please yes i'm a
big fan of mr carroll's books thanks um
it's like a page turner you just can't
put it down whenever you read your books
my question is about lbj i think he's
the greatest when he passes the civil
rights laws but i think he might be the
worst when it comes to the war on
poverty and the 5 trillion
and i think that that it didn't aid the
negro either when they started receiving
all the welfare
i'm wondering if he did that money the
voting of the welfare to keep blacks
indebted to the democratic party thanks
uh
i've said too many times today that i
haven't finished my own
work on that so i don't know i don't
know the answer to that excellent
question here's a question from kurt
lundgren of minneapolis has any new
information surfaced in the interviewing
years which would affect what you've
written in volumes one and two of the
years of lyndon johnson specifically the
white house tape recordings
nothing that would affect anything over
i asked you earlier about the white
house table cranes by the way have you
listened to them oh yeah i've listened
to a lot of them yeah
san francisco you're on the air
san francisco go ahead please hello yes
sir
yes uh i have uh three questions uh one
mr um
in your approach to your subjects
do you consider yourself a writer or a
historian
and what in your opinion is the
difference
the second
question i have is more about how you do
your work
do you write in longhand or computer or
a typewriter
and then the third question is
lyndon johnson is supposed to have said
something to the effect
that the passage of the voting right act
in 1965
would lead to the demise of the
democratic party and the south
do you know whether he said that
and if he believed this in 1965
he must have censored in 1957
so why then do you suppose that he
pushed ahead with the civil rights act
in 1957 thanks
to take the middle question because i
don't want these three hours to pass
with all you out there under a
misapprehension about the fact that i'm
a luddite i actually write in pencil my
first few drafts and then i uh
type on a typewriter and i i don't use a
computer
um
the uh do i consider myself a writer or
historian that's actually a a great
question because i i consider myself
both and i think that if we had time to
talk about that we'd really get to the
heart of a lot about history in america
today first i have to do everything the
historian does i have to go through all
the papers all the archives i have to do
the interviews i have to do the research
now there are some historians
david mccullough
edmond morris
others
who
also are wonderful writers
and do what i then try to do which is to
say i'm not just going to put the facts
down i'm going to make the right the
reader see
what was happening feel what was
happening because that's the truest way
of showing history if passing the 1957
civil rights act was thrilling and it
was thrilling isn't it being untrue to
history if you don't make the reader
feel that drama and that thrill we're
out of time but i'm going to grab this
one quickly from washington dc for
robert carroll go ahead please
hello
turn your tv down please and keep
talking we're out of time it's something
that i wanted to say if i had to write
it myself
lyndon johnson has done more for black
people in his presidency than any
president lincoln yes that has his place
kennedy know even though they had
pictures of him lyndon johnson i have
documented that and i've always wanted
to tell mr johnson that and thank you
sir
good note then
we're not ready but will the blacks like
what they read about what he thought
behind the scenes about mexicans and
black people
no they certainly won't
and in the end do you think he did it
sincerely or do you think it was a
cynical move on his part for his own
political reasons i think
oh i think neither of those things i
think it's so much an into a complicated
intermingling of things that i i've only
begun to deal with it in this book and
it's going to get more complicated yet
when you get the book if you buy it this
is what the inside cover looks like it's
the senate when lyndon johnson was there
without the television lights and the
television cameras here's what the cover
looks like it will be in your bookstores
on april the 23rd the third book about
lyndon johnson by robert carroll he's
worked on his
subject for over 25 years where our
three hours are up and we thank you for
joining us thank you for having me and
to our audience have a good day
you've been watching in depth with
robert carrow
if you missed any portion of the
three-hour interview you can see it
again at 5 pm eastern and later at
midnight
[Music]